nous ouvrons cet après-midi nos travaux
avec la Table Ronde des représentants de
syndicats de police cette table ronde
est ouverte à la presse et comme vous
pouvez le voir elle est diffusée en
direct sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale je vous souhaite madame et
messieurs à tous la bienvenue et je vous
remercie d'avoir répondu à l'invitation
de notre commission d'enquête nous
cherchons et je pense que vous vous en
doutez à comprendre les éclats de
violence qui ont marqué les
manifestations de ce printemps et à
évaluer la réponse qui leur a été
apportée par les autorités publiques
comme vous le savez nous avons déjà
entendu votre directeur général à ce
propos
ainsi que vos camarades du conseil de la
fonction militaire de la gendarmerie
nationale même si structuration est un
peu différente mais ils étaient présents
à cette place la semaine dernière un
questionnaire par ailleurs vous a été
préalablement transmis par notre
rapporteur monsieur Florent Boudier
toutes les questions que contient ce
questionnaire ne pourront évidemment pas
être évoqué oralement de manière
exhaustive donc je vous invite par
conséquent à nous communiquer
ultérieurement les éléments de réponse
écrit que vous jugerez utile de porter à
la connaissance de notre commission
d'enquête comme vous êtes nombreux et
susceptible de vous exprimer je vais
vous demander comme le veut l'usage de
prêter serment les uns après les autres
donc et puis ensuite je serai amené à à
vous poser quelques premières questions
ensuite vous pourrez y répondre et puis
bien entendu je donnerai voilà monsieur
le rapporteur ainsi qu'aux autres
membres de la commission dans un second
temps donc avant tout cela il me revient
donc d'ouvrir les débats et je le ferai
en vous soumettant deux interrogations
qui traversent les travaux de notre
commission en premier lieu nous avons
entendu plusieurs personnes qui ont
souligné que les violences de ce
printemps
s'inscrivaient dans un continuum
historique et qu'elle n'avait rien
d'exceptionnel au regard des faits
passés du moins au cours des dernières
décennies
confirmez vous ce jugement ou au
contraire voyez vous émerger des
phénomènes nouveaux au cours des
derniers mois donc
et quels sont les éléments que vous
pouvez apporter à l'appréciation de la
commission par rapport à cela comment
parmiez-vous et quelles difficultés
rencontrez-vous pour cela à concilier
évidemment le maintien de l'ordre lors
des manifestations et l'interpellation
des auteurs de violence avec la présence
de tierce personne manifestants services
d'ordre élu journaliste services de
santé c'est une question que nous avons
abordée pas plus tard qu'hier soir avec
Madame la procureur de Paris puisque
elle insistait sur le fait que les
situations étaient souvent complexes et
que les forces de l'ordre et bien
étaient bien pris il fallait à la fois
achurer le maintien de l'ordre et puis
dans le feu de l'action évidemment aussi
faire en sorte que l'on puisse dans un
second temps éventuellement engagé des
actions judiciaires lorsque un certain
nombre de faits étaient commis
pensez-vous que les coordinations sont
bien réalisées en amont ou qu'une marge
de progression existe avec certains de
ces acteurs auquel cas ça peut nous
intéresser dans la mesure où le rôle
d'une commission d'enquête et de mettre
l'accent évidemment sur ce qui semble
fonctionner ce qui peut être
éventuellement améliorer et ce qui
éventuellement peut aussi donner lieu à
des dysfonctionnements alors comme je
l'indiqué à l'instant avant de vous
donner la parole et en application de
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance numéro
58-1100 du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires françaises j'ai
maintenant vous demander de prêter
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité je vous
propose les uns après les autres de
lever la main droite enfin préalablement
en ayant appuyé sur votre micro et puis
vous le ferez évidemment en chaîne levez
la main droite et de dire je le jure
pour que cette prestation de serment
soit je dirais acté et officiel donc
Subway je vous passe déjà la parole
très bien merci beaucoup donc je le jure
je vous remercie je vous laisse voilà
donc Denis Jacob je le jure
Guillaume Ruet je le jure madame
messieurs je vous remercie et donc sans
tarder je vous passe la parole je pense
que je vous laisse le soin de décider
l'ordre d'intervention
de faire
par rapport au groupuscule aux
manifestation on peut aujourd'hui que
les actions contre les forces de l'ordre
sans de plus en plus violente alors
qu'en parallèle les contrats
déontologiques que l'on pose aux
policiers sont de plus en plus pesantes
les policiers abcès déontologique mais
lorsque ces derniers sont dénoncés à
tort sur les plateformes de l'IGPN ou
dans les médias l'administration ne
réagit pas ils ne peuvent compter que
sur les syndicats de police notre autre
hiérarchie ne dénonce pas suffisamment
l'utilisation abusive du terme violence
policière on constate augmentation des
violences à l'égard des forces de
l'ordre au gré des manifestations ou des
individus radicalisés appartenant ou non
à des mouvements violents
majoritairement du bras gauche viennent
casser brûler pieds et surtout agresser
ou essayer de tuer toute personne
représentant l'autorité de l'État dont
les forces de police et deux gendarmerie
on peut assister dans ce cadre à une
désinhibition totale de ses adversaires
qui utilisent de façon concertée et
organisée des méthodes et des techniques
de guerrier urbaine et qui utilise dans
ce cadre des armes de guerre cocktail
Molotov bombe à l'acide ou à la soude
bomb artisanale exposif etc cette
désinhibition est sans doute un problème
sociétal de rapport à l'autorité et de
sa remise en cause systématique
aujourd'hui on agresse un président de
la République des élus députés sénateurs
maire mais aussi les pompiers les
professeurs les médecins et surtout ceux
qui sont premiers lignes pour les
défendre les forces de l'ordre on parle
de désobéissance civile pour ceux qui
violent la loi dans le cadre de
l'expression d'une contestation sociale
participation du manifestation interdite
par exemple c'est désobéissance civile
est soutenu d'ailleurs et régulièrement
par certains groupes politiques ces gens
l'Assemblée nationale ce soutien
légitimes de façon systématique et
systémique l'action de police en
légitimement pas écoché l'action des
délinquants
conforté dans le fait que la police
n'est pas légitime dans l'exercice de
son autorité beaucoup d'activistes
considèrent l'action de police comme
illégale et ce rebelle violemment contre
tout exercice de l'autorité par la
police les aime métiers sont confortés
dans leur idée que leur cause est
légitime par le fait qu'ils sont
rarement condamnés problème de peureux
mais aussi problème de magistrats qui
pour certains ne rendent pas la justice
au nom du peuple français non loin de
leur conviction politique et syndicales
le maintien de l'ordre est une opération
de police administrative en unité
constituée le fait d'individualiser
judiciairement la responsabilité des
agents tant à inhiber fortement l'action
de police le harcèlement juridique et la
spécialité de l'extrême gauche qui pour
tout usage de la force légitime par la
police est considéré comme une violence
policière voilà on tenait avoir ses
propos on prend bulle pour un peu
marquer notre message dessus merci
je vous remercie est-ce que quelqu'un
d'autre souhaite prendre le relais
oui je vous en prie
oui merci
moi je vais directement répondre à vos
deux questions monsieur le député la
première s'agissant du phénomène Black
Bloc c'est pas nouveau vous le disiez
très justement mais il s'est vraiment
affirmé lors des manifestations contre
la loi travail en 2016 et c'est là qu'on
a véritablement vu une émergence du
phénomène black bloc avec une véhicité à
Hong Kong des forces de sécurité et une
volonté d'aller au contact et d'agresser
les forces de sécurité ce que nous ne
connaissions pas historiquement dans le
maintien de l'ordre dit à la française
où on avait toujours un maintien de
l'ordre de tenir à distance mais ne
jamais d'être au compte au contact et on
l'a connu véritablement
une affirmation de ce phénomène Black
Bloc lors de des manifestations en 2016
contre la loi el khomri à l'époque nous
avions et je vous remercie d'ailleurs de
nous recevoir dans ce cadre de la
commission d'enquête qui s'inscrit
malheureusement dans la continuité de
précédente audition qu'on avait pu avoir
notamment à l'occasion des
manifestations violentes que nous avions
connues lors des des gilets jaunes des
manifestations des gilets jaunes et puis
plus récemment lors des des
manifestations relatives à la réforme
des retraites et dès 2016 nous n'avions
déjà préconisé de traiter en amont le
problème des violences notamment
par une révision du schéma du maintien
de l'ordre ce qui a été fait très
récemment et notamment nous avions porté
au titre de la CFDT la création de ces
médiateurs qu'on appelle en France les
équipes de liaison et d'informations
mais également de doter les forces de
sécurité de véhicule comme en Allemagne
sonore et lumineux pour bien prévenir
les manifestants pacifiques quand les
forces de l'ordre vont passer à l'action
et bien qu'on puisse nous dans le cadre
de nos interventions pour lutter contre
les affrontements avoir véritablement
affaire au casseurs et non pas à voir
dans le lot des manifestants pacifiques
qui
des événements vont malheureusement
démontrés ont été en grande partie les
personnes qui ont été interpellées et
placées en garde à vue on pourront
revenir dessus si vous voulez plus tard
mais les Black Blocs c'est un mouvement
qui est organisé
préparer
qui ont anticipé l'action notamment via
les réseaux sociaux tout cela est
convenu et ça dépasse les frontières de
la France c'est un phénomène européen on
le sait à chaque fois qu'il y a des
manifestations sociales à travers les
différents pays européens il y a des
mouvements de Black Bloc et je pense
qu'il est important de prendre en
considération que le traitement des
blackploc ne peut pas être
franco-français et ne peut pas être fait
uniquement sur la seule action des
forces de sécurité considérer que les
forces de sécurité française toutes
seules régleront le phénomène de
violence des Black Blocs des casseurs
sur les manifestations c'est se tromper
de débats je pense que c'est important
de de le rappeler
donc il faut recontextualiser tout cela
c'est un mouvement qui ne porte sur
aucune revendication qui ne provoque
aucun slogan d'ordre social syndical
écologiste ou autre mais qui
n'intervient uniquement que dans le
cadre de mettre en péril les symboles
républicains et démocratiques donc voilà
succinctement pour répondre à la
première question sur la seconde
question peut-être qu'on y reviendra
tout à l'heure je ne sais pas en
fonction de comment vous souhaitez
dérouler cette entretien en tous les cas
il y a effectivement une question de
d'acteurs de complémentarité d'action et
pour alternative police elle porte
principalement sur la judiciarisation
des interpellations en lien avec la
magistrature
on a un problème de traitement
judiciaire des personnes interpellées ça
l'a malheureusement été le cas dans la
mettre dans les manifestations contre
les retraites vous avez des
fonctionnaires qui interviennent sur sur
un cadre d'affrontement violent qui
interpelle qui font une fiche
synthétique de présentation à un OPJ de
la personne interpellée on l'amène au
commissariat et l'interpellateur
retourne sur le théâtre des
affrontements il ne reste pas en
présence et ensuite pour l'enquêteur il
est particulièrement compliqué d'établir
la responsabilité d'un ou plusieurs
auteurs de violence donc nous pensons au
titre d'internetive police que de cette
judiciarisation doit être faite
directement sur le terrain alors on
commence à voir quelques dispositifs et
nous on préconise une généralisation
d'un dispositif de bus de bus d'opgi à
même les théâtres de violence alors pas
pas naturellement dans les affrontements
mais en retrait mais avec donc des mises
à disposition mobile dans lequel on a
des officiers de police judiciaire qui
prennent des plinthes en direct l'agent
présente l'interpellé il peut tout de
suite témoigner de ce qu'il a vu de ce
qui s'est passé et l'OPGI à tous les
éléments caractéristiques une petite
matérialisée pour pouvoir ensuite mettre
cette personne en garde à vue et le cas
échéant ensuite le présenter un
magistrat donc je pense que c'est sur
ces deux axes qu'il faut qu'il faut
travailler bien évidemment il y a
d'autres moyens que l'on peut mettre à
disposition dans le cadre de l'action
partenariat avec les magistrats et
surtout dans l'enquête de
judiciarisation et nous avions préconisé
préconisé également en 2016 ça n'a pas
été effectif malheureusement
mais on doit pouvoir aussi travailler à
posteriori et ne pas se retrouver comme
on l'a été confronté à une grande
majorité de personnes placées en garde à
vue qui ensuite ont été libérés faute de
de charges contre elles nous
préconisions dès 2016 la dotation pour
les forces de sécurité de nouvelles
armes non létales que sont les marqueurs
les traceurs ADN chimiques tels qu'on
les connaît dans les établissements
bancaires et qui permet de marquer la
peau d'un produit
qui reste indélébile pendant près de six
semaines et qui dans le cadre d'une
enquête à posteriori permet d'identifier
des auteurs de d'infraction de délits et
de pouvoir les interpeller par la suite
de les mettre à disposition de la
justice donc voilà un peu le travail
partenariat que nous souhaiterions
sur le terrain avec les magistrats en
lien direct on sait que on a toujours
tendance à jeter la pierre sur la
magistrature sur la justice et l'on sait
que la justice comme la police nationale
a de gros problèmes de de moyens même si
beaucoup d'efforts ont été faits
récemment pour la police nationale il
faut qu'il en soit de même pour la
justice et que la justice puisse avoir
les moyens de suivre l'action de la
police et donc on pense que ce travail
partenarial avec la magistrature
directement en temps réel sur des
théâtres d'affrontement lors de
manifestations face à des Black Blocs
peut-être une solution notamment avec
ses bus mobiles dans lesquels dans
lesquels on pourrait mettre des OPJ
merci
merci beaucoup monsieur Jacob pour ces
éléments alors ça ça permet de de
rebondir par rapport à ce que vous dites
sur sur au moins deux points et fait
réagir aussi
les à la fois l'INSA et Alliance police
par rapport par rapport à cela vous
indiquez que les Black Blocs tels que
vous les voyez aujourd'hui ils sont
organisés préparer avant de d'aller sur
sur un terrain de manifestations et donc
en fait le la difficulté que nous avons
repéré au cours des précédentes
auditions c'est que à contrario cette
préparation
a comme conséquence que il est de plus
en plus difficile d'apporter la preuve
de la présence de certaines personnes
sur
sur des des situations précises et donc
vous vous apportez un début de réponse
en disant il faut que la judiciarisation
se fasse directement sur sur le terrain
c'est vrai que hier soir Madame la
procureur de de Paris a insisté sur le
fait que évidemment la magistrature va
se baser sur des preuves et donc dans un
état de droit il faut apporter la preuve
que la personne de manière précise à
commis tel ou telle fait et que bien
entendu dans le feu de l'action les
fiches telles qu'elles sont renseignées
par les OPJ dans un certain nombre de
cash sont incomplètes et ces fiches
incomplètes ne permettent pas à la
magistrature de de procéder je dirais à
ce qui ce qui est leur mode opératoire
habituel c'est-à-dire établir manière
précise l'épreuve est-ce que cette cette
idée de judiciarisation directement sur
le terrain avec
comme vous l'indiquez puisque ça
commençait à se faire des bus qui
permettent de faire en sorte que et bien
le la personne qui a procédé à
l'interpellation peut directement en
quelque sorte apporter son témoignage à
l'OPJ pour que comment dire il y ait une
fiche bien renseignée est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui fait consensus
entre vous est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
propositions qui sont formulées pour en
réalité faire en sorte que l'écart se
réduise entre je dirais le nombre de
fiches établis et puis et puis les
sanctions judiciaires dès lors que les
les preuves sont évidemment apportées
quoi
bien évidemment en fait le la
problématique c'est le temps court c'est
à dire que dès que le l'individu est
interpellé la présentation à l'OPJ la
vie magistrat pose le vrai sujet donc
effectivement la le l'idée d'un bus
mobile ou autre qui suivrait
effectivement ça reste une bonne idée
puisque ça reste le ça reste le temps de
notification garde à vue d'avis
magistrayante mais il y a aussi le
problème de la matérialisation les
individus sont tous noirs ils sont tous
ils sont tous tous masqués ils ont tous
pour qu'on signe parce qu'il y a quand
même des consignes qui sont données de
ne pas parler donc ils ne disent rien
tant qu'ils ont pas la présence d'un
avocat et en général ce sont des avocats
qui sont spécialisés dans ce domaine
donc il y a des vrais des vrais sujets
donc après la vraie preuve serait de de
capter l'image d'avoir la vidéo mais ça
reste encore très dur dans un schéma de
de de maintien d'ordre après sur la
première question aussi les violences
rien d'exceptionnel si si les dernières
violences ont été particulièrement
importantes d'ailleurs le ressenti
rejoindre notre puce puisqu'il est
responsable des CRS mais ils ont
rarement vu une telle une hôtel violence
après il y a tous ces tous ces
groupuscules sont maintenant même si
partage des opinions diverses d'extrême
droite extrême gauche de de animaparti
animaliste écologiste moi il se retrouve
tous derrière une même cause le temps de
d'une manifestation et voilà c'est des
des idéologies anti-gapitalistes des
logis anti anti-o tout ce qui représente
l'État et il y avait une particularité
ils sont pas hiérarchisés il y a pas de
chef il a pas on peut pas faire tomber
le chef du non c'est à dire qu'ils
fonctionnent ils se réunissent c'est par
des des messageries sécurisées donc oui
effectivement il y a un vrai sujet mais
le d'avoir l'OPJ au plus près reste une
bonne idée néanmoins le sujet restera la
matérialisation de la preuve
très bien est-ce que quelqu'un d'autre
souhaiterait agir oui
pour matérialiser les faits et les
compagnies républicaines de sécurité
quand elles sont en maintien de l'ordre
et en unité constituée les
fonctionnaires et les agents des ses
compagnies républicaines de sécurité
perdent leur qualité d'agent de police
judiciaire donc c'est pour ça qu'en fait
c'est vraiment des des fiches techniques
qui sont faites et établies c'est
vraiment synthétique après le collègue
en unité constituée une fois qui l'a
fait son interpellation il rejoint très
rapidement ses collègues qui sont restés
sur le terrain il ne reste pas avec
l'individu interpellé en fait il ne fait
juste que le le transfert donc voilà
c'est c'est la qualité donc le collègue
ne peut pas lui-même dire voilà ce que
cet individu a commis
a commis comme fait voilà lui dans ce
cadre de rétablissement de l'ordre
public c'est-à-dire que des instructions
ont été données pour rétablir grand
public c'est à dire que cette personne
est là au mauvais endroit au mauvais
endroit au mauvais moment donc on
l'interpelle et on le remet à l'OPJ
voilà
après les caméras vidéos
actuellement tout les tous les
fonctionnaires des compagnies
républicaines n'en sont pas dotés
ça commence à arriver donc est-ce que il
va falloir peut-être de mieux en mieux
exploiter
le système vidéo qu'on les agents sur
eux voilà et je pense qu'on pourra avec
ces caméras matérialisées un petit peu
mieux l'effet concomit ces personnes
merci beaucoup je vois que Monsieur
Jacob souhaite également réagir je vous
passe aussi la parole merci oui je vais
réagir un peu à tout ce que peuvent
avoir dit mais mes collègues à l'instant
il faut savoir qu'effectivement les
Black Blocs interviennent tous en noir
ils arrivent comme une personne lambda
dans une manifestation et au top donné
il se met tous en noir donc c'est vrai
que la matérialisation d'une infraction
surtout quand c'est en fin de
manifestation ça se produit donc il fait
souvent surtout en hiver il fait nuit
donc difficile d'identifier en temps
réel qui a fait quoi il faut savoir
quand même que dans les groupuscules de
Black Box vous avez en gros 40% de
meneurs et le reste ce sont des suiveurs
parce que mon collègue je disais il n'y
a pas de hiérarchie de leader établi
dans les mouvements de Black Blocs donc
nous pensons qu'effectivement la caméra
piéton généralisée qui a déjà pris des
proportions très importantes qui ont été
mises en place ces dernières années et
capitales de façon à avoir le poids des
images vous savez qu'aujourd'hui tout
est malheureusement retransmis en direct
sur les réseaux sociaux et souvent pour
mettre en cause l'action des forces de
sécurité donc il faut que nous aussi on
ait la matérialisation de la preuve par
l'image et puis saluer aussi ce que nous
demandions depuis longtemps c'est
l'usage des drones parce que c'est très
très important d'avoir un drone qui va
avoir une vue d'ensemble sur un théâtre
d'affrontement de voir comment on agit
les individus comment ils sont partis
vers les forces de sécurité comment nous
nous sommes intervenus et
potentiellement aussi nous servir à
réajuster nos modes d'action
mais en amont nous pensons et je le
répète qu'il faut agir et pour cela je
pense qu'il sera important de légiférer
pour un ciblage efficace de ces auteurs
pour une violence moins importante ce
qui permettra une participation en
nombre réduit et l'absence probable de
suiveur vous avez un peu les féminisme
avec les Black Blocs vous avez toutes un
tas de personnes qui s'agrègent à ces
mouvements là parce que ils portent des
mouvements de mécontentement et donc ils
suivent et donc pour éviter d'être
confronté à ça et bien je pense qu'il
faut légiférer et l'efficacité de la loi
sera de s'attaquer au noyau dur des
Black Blocs et pour ça nous on pense
qu'il serait utile de réfléchir à la
création notamment d'une fiche
d'interdit de manifestation comme ça là
existe déjà pour les interdits de stade
avec une procédure similaire ou la
personne doit aller pointer quand on
sait qu'il va y avoir une manifestation
à tel endroit et bien personne doit
aller pointer dans le commissariat où il
est référencé de façon à ce qu'on sache
que s'il y a des affrontements et bien
cette personne qui était préalablement
fichée n'était pas présente dans le
théâtre de des exactions voilà ce que je
souhaitais apporter comme complément
d'information je vous remercie merci
beaucoup pour cette précision vous savez
que pour légiférer
pour un ciblage efficace
on se heurte à quelques difficultés
parfois d'ordre constitutionnel puisque
évidemment participer à une
manifestation dans un stade n'est pas
considéré comme de même nature que le
droit fondamental de de manifester et
donc c'est vrai que il faut arriver à
trouver tirer le bon vecteur juridique
pour pour régler cette cette question
mais je pense qu'effectivement
il y a il y a une nécessité en tout cas
de de trouver là une voix qui à la fois
évidemment respecte la const solution
mais qui par ailleurs puissent aussi
garantir justement
de manifester en sécurité
et c'est effectivement devenu une
difficulté vous évoquiez le fait que
comment dire vous vous avez du mal à
dire à procéder à une identification des
Black Blocs est-ce que là il y a des
vous faites des propositions est-ce
qu'il y a des choses où vous dites il
faudrait
il faudrait justement légiférer sur ce
point précis ou pas quand on a cette
difficulté d'identification et
d'interpellation je pense que enfin en
ce qui concerne mon organisation
syndicale je pense que les traceurs ADN
dans le cadre des procédures judiciaires
peut être une solution à posteriori
parce que quand on est confronté à ce
genre d'affrontement
on risque malheureusement quand on
n'arrive pas à interpeller les les
auteurs réels d'avoir des dommages
collatéraux malheureusement comme on a
pu le connaître
par le passé et les forces de sécurité
n'interviennent pas pour le plaisir
d'aller excusez-moi du terme mais casser
la figure aux manifestants pacifiques
qui se trouve pris un peu entre le
marteau et l'enclume des Black Blocs
d'un côté des casseurs et des forces de
sécurité de l'autre donc je pense que ça
c'est un élément important et puis des
moyens audibles d'indications aux
manifestants pacifique que quand on est
sur le point de d'intervenir sur des
théâtres d'affrontements et bien qu'ils
doivent partir parce que quand on est
bien informé de manière audible que la
police va intervenir qu'il y a un
théâtre d'affrontement qui a une
confrontation et que on reste malgré
tout et bien je dirais il faut en
assumer aussi la responsabilité
c'est-à-dire que
quand on est dans une manifestation et
qu'on participe même sans agir mais à la
violence il faut pas venir ensuite dire
on s'est pris un mauvais coup parce que
quand on passe à l'action on va
interpeller et on va pas prendre le
temps de faire le tri de savoir qui a
fait quoi on nous donne des ordres
d'intervenir de mettre un terme à
l'ordre un trouble à l'ordre public on
intervient on y met un terme et
malheureusement dans le nombre de
personnes qu'on peut interpeller on peut
avoir des personnes qui n'ont rien à
voir sauf que ces personnes là n'est
peut-être mal été informé au départ et
que avoir aussi certains nombres de
dispositifs qui permettent clairement de
d'indiquer les choses aux manifestants
permettra aussi à chacun d'endosser la
responsabilité qu'il doit endosser si
malgré tout il est resté dans dans les
affrontements je pense que ce sont deux
moyens que l'on peut utiliser et
s'agissant de légiférer monsieur le
député sur les fiches moi je pense que
oui au niveau de notre pays il faut
qu'on réfléchisse à trouver le juste
équilibre juridique pour pouvoir trouver
quelque chose qui permet d'anticiper la
présence de ces Black Blocs mais je
pense que c'est aussi et surtout un
travail européen qu'on doit avoir sur ce
sujet là puisque il y a quand même
beaucoup de personnes qui viennent des
pays frontaliers notamment les Pays-Bas
l'Allemagne la Belgique qui sont connus
aussi pour entre guillemets héberger des
Black Blocs je pense que vous savez des
Black Blocs ils ont des stages de
formation ils sont préparés à
l'affrontement
avec les forces de sécurité et qu'en
général les premiers qui sont
interpellés par les forces de sécurité
c'est pas des Black Blocs tes blagues
blocs ce sont déjà globalement sauvés
donc je pense que ça aussi ça doit être
un débat qui doit être porté au niveau
de l'Europe
très bien sûr sur cette question là on
nous aurons une audition de la part d'un
dirigeant de RuPaul qui devrait
justement nous permettre aussi d'avoir
un éclairage sur un qu'est-ce qui se
fait à l'étranger d'autre part comment
peut y avoir une coordination sur
précisément sur cette question monsieur
cavalero je vous en prie oui je voulais
aussi enfin intervenir il faut aussi
différencier tout ce qui est
manifestation autorisées et non
autorisés parce que souvent enfin
beaucoup de choses je prends l'exemple
de la manifestation par exemple de
samedi sur l'axe Lyon Turin c'est une
définition qui est interdite ça il y a
des gens qui sont présents donc déjà dès
le départ ils sont en infraction c'est
important de différencier un peu tout ça
parce que lorsqu'il y a des débordements
des fois on rejette un peu un peu la
faute sur des manifestations classiques
ou autre on l'a connu ça un peu sur les
gilets jaunes ce qui était rassemblement
en fait il y a eu en fait les
attroupements le terme c'est ça et très
peu d'individus ont été condamnés par
rapport à ça c'est une infraction qui
existe mais qui a été très peu utilisé
ça c'est un premier point donc quand des
gens sont rassemblement qui interdit
en fait je dois pas y avoir de débat qui
qui s'éternise en fait c'est interdit
enfin comme on dit force de rester à la
loi donc on doit avoir l'action de
police qui doit arriver ensuite vous
avez des manifestations manifestations
qui sont dites classiques encadré par
des services de d'ordre des syndicats ou
souvent les 60 de manifestations ou à la
fin de l'effectation c'est des choses
qui sont qui sont un peu différentes
parce que lorsque vous avez déjà
rassemblement qui sont interdits il y a
un dispositif qui met en place on suit
etc là on peut intervenir enfin il faut
intervenir dès le départ c'est pas
normal non plus qu'à travers des
manifestations interdites on retrouve
des élus sur plein de choses là où c'est
ça ça pose problème soit les
manifestation qui sont autorisés souvent
c'est la dislocation et on revient un
petit peu à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure sur le continent de violence
parce qu'effectivement les back box ce
sont depuis je peux déjà même depuis
Évian depuis le sommet d'Évian en 2003
ils sont présents ils s'habituent comme
disait le collègue c'est que à la fin
aussi les les gens qui restent les
badogènes l'action des forces de l'ordre
pour pouvoir intervenir rapidement ce
que le but c'est du TBC et lorsque
l'accent des forces n'est pas n'est pas
gêné on peut progresser arriver
interpeller les auteurs qui sont masqués
ou autre mais en tout cas actuellement
les interpelle mais il y a aussi avoir
la coordination entre les forces parce
que comment dirais-je l'essai au départ
solo pour établir l'ordre on peut
considérer que d'autres forces sont là
pour interpeller par exemple parce que
lorsque vous interpellez vous l'évoquez
tout à l'heure il y a des fils du mise à
disposition mais il faut pas non plus
dénaturer le dispositif policier qui est
mis en place parce qu'on tient des axes
on tient sur pas mal de choses donc là
aussi ça doit être une alchimie qui doit
qui doit rentrer en ligne de compte mais
comme aussi on n'a pas évoqué non plus
c'est les gens qui sont présents dans le
cas du cinéma on parle de la presse mais
aujourd'hui tout le monde se présente de
la presse avec des appareils pour
photographier ou autre c'est ce qui gêne
aussi beaucoup l'action des forces de
l'ordre on l'a vu sur différentes
manifestations les gens le plus tôt
d'intervenir filme regarde les gens
cassés vous frapper d'autres
manifestants sans intervenir ici mais
c'est ce qui gêne aussi l'action des
forces de l'ordre puis les collègues
sont rapides pour intervenir il y a pas
de débat à partir du moment ils
interpellent le groupe le collègue la
personne qui est masquée ou pas masqué
une fois qu'elle interpellé on arrive en
matière matérialiser mais c'est vrai que
si c'est fait dans un temps qui se qui
quelques temps après c'est là où c'est
difficile de de matérialiser la fraction
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
la parole à Monsieur le Rapporteur puis
ensuite vous pourrez évidemment répondre
à ces questions
oui merci monsieur le Président merci à
vous toutes à vous tous
d'être venu à notre audition et nous
n'oublions pas au moment où nous
auditionnons que les hommes et les
femmes que vous représentez à travers
vos organisations ont été en première
ligne face au groupuscule violon dont
nous essayons d'étudier d'analyser faut
aller modalités d'action
à ce propos première question nous
étudions les la question relevant de la
structuration de financement des
groupuscules violents selon les
premières auditions la structuration est
plutôt molle
les financements plutôt inexistants en
tout cas faibles est-ce que vous
confirmez ce point de vue question
concernant le schéma national de
maintien de l'ordre comment concilier on
voit que c'est une des grandes
difficultés à la fois la mise à distance
qui permet d'éviter la le plus possible
la confrontation sachant que les forces
de l'ordre n'ont pas pour vocation de
provoquer elle-même évidemment nous
l'avons bien compris à travers nos
auditions la mise à distance et la
mobilité voir l'hyper mobilité il y a là
parfois des difficultés concrètes
opérationnelles auxquelles vous êtes
confronté comment vous voyez cet
articulation elle est forcément
difficile dans des théâtres d'opérations
qui eux-mêmes sont compliqués par le
comportement de celles et ceux qui sont
en face de vous
toujours concernant le schéma national
de maintien de l'ordre
le préfet de police de Paris nous
indiquait voici quelques jours que
probablement que du côté de la meilleure
communication ou de la meilleure
information à destination des
manifestants j'allais dire des vrais
manifestants sans doute qu'il y avait
des progrès à faire pour tenter
notamment pas uniquement mais notamment
au moment de la dispersion faire en
sorte des informations sur le fait que
la confrontation ou l'affrontement les
violences étaient étaient en cours ou
allait se dérouler qu'il y avait une
dispersion nécessaire qu'il fallait par
conséquent mettre de côté la
manifestation on va dire classique
ordinaire légitime pacifiste pour
pouvoir intervenir vis-à-vis des
individus violents est-ce que vous
confirmez du point de vue opérationnel
cette nécessité quels sont les outils
dont vous seriez utile que nos forces de
l'ordre puissent se doter sachant que le
police par exemple nous indiquer que
lorsque la tentative a été faite de
mettre en place des panneaux
d'information encore faut-il qu'il
résiste à des pavés à des cocktails
Molotov et donc à une brutalité
particulière je viens de prononcer un
mot brutalité
je me fais signe dans l'avocat du diable
en tout cas celui de la contradiction en
tant que importante de la commission
d'enquête comment vous appréhendez ces
notions parfois ces expressions qui sont
faites y compris au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale de brutalisation j'allais dire
presque systémique vous avez évoqué la
notion de violence policière comment
vous appréhendez ces expressions qui
sont parfois faites y compris au sein
même de notre institution elles ont été
parfois nombreuses de la même façon que
comment vous vous répondez à celles de
ceux qui indiquent
je pense à Sainte Soline en particulier
mais pas que bien sûr au fond tout cela
a été prévisible et donc évitable
comment vous répondez à cette critique
qui parfois a été mise j'ai vu parfois
des tribus y compris de chercheurs
universitaires il est tout ça était à la
fois prévisible et donc évitables
comment vous répondez à ce genre de
interrogation portée par un certain
nombre de de personnes et puis ensuite
dernière question elle est délicate
également
c'est plus qui d'entre vous
a évoqué le comportement d'un certain
nombre de familles politiques je suis
extrêmement prudent parce que nous
sommes ici à l'Assemblée nationale et
mon rôle est de mettre en cause personne
mais est-ce que
quelle ligne de partage vous faites je
pense que c'est une question essentielle
entre ceux qui relève
de la colère exprimée
voire de l'accompagnement d'une colère
exprimée quand on est élu on peut aussi
se faire le porte-parole de certains de
colère
et la ligne de démarcation avec la
violence proprement dit de voir
l'incitation à la violence on voit bien
que dans la période récente c'est un
vrai débat et qu'il y a des expressions
politiques dont on se demande si elle se
situe dans l'accompagnement de colère ou
si elles ont déjà basculées dans la
légitimation de la violence voir jusqu'à
l'incitation à la violence quel est
votre regard sur un sujet qui est un
vrai sujet de débat
vous le voyez beaucoup de questions de
la part de notre rapporteur donc je là
aussi je vous laisse le soin de choisir
dans quel ordre vous souhaitez répondre
l'objectif est évidemment que l'ensemble
de vos organisations puisse à travers
vous madame et Messieurs évidemment
exprimé leur leur regard et leur point
de vue sur la question monsieur
nassimato donc je veux revenir un petit
peu sur le nouveau schéma national du
maintien de l'ordre il faut savoir
qu'avant la création de ce nouveau
schéma national du maintien de l'ordre
le maintien de l'ordre à la française et
reconnu dans le monde entier et a été
reconnu également par l'ONU en 1965 et
reconnu également par le Conseil de
l'Europe
le schéma national du maintien de
l'ordre à essayer de mettre essaye de
mettre en place certaines
certains points concernant les fameux
tableaux comme on le dites les tableaux
pour alerter pour que les manifestants
soient alertés que il y aura peut-être
une action de la police
je veux revenir sur la préparation sur
les préparations du maintien de l'ordre
il faut que tous les acteurs et je vais
surtout parler ici sur la plaque
parisienne du maintien de l'ordre sur la
plaque parisienne c'est à dire sur la
préfecture de police
il faut que vous il faut qu'on que vous
sachiez que jusqu'à très peu de temps
encore les forces mobiles
les forces mobiles c'est à dire les
compagnies républicaines de sécurité
n'était pas ne faisait pas partie des
réunions préparatoires au maintien de
l'ordre au maintien de l'ordre tout ça
était décidé au sein même de la
préfecture de police sans sans réunion
au préalable avec avec les les
spécialistes du maintien de l'ordre
après sur le maintien de l'ordre
également
il y a la partie de tout ce qui est
sommation et utilisation de la de la
force légitime
sur la plaque parisienne on je vous dis
clairement on peut se poser le problème
de l'autorité civile
l'autorité civile qui est un commissaire
de police qui est l'autorité civile sur
le maintien de l'ordre qui donne des
objectifs à atteindre
d'accord s'il faut évacuer une place il
dit voilà vous il se retourne vers le
commandant de la force publique qui lui
est le seul légitime à utiliser la force
et sur la plate parisienne
à plusieurs reprises nous avons
donc l'autorité civile qui fait les deux
les deux et pour nous à l'INSA police
cela pose problème dans le
rétablissement de l'ordre public
je parle bien dans le rétablissement de
l'ordre public comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure le le donc l'autorité
civile donne les sommations les
sommations l'objectif à atteindre et le
commandant de la force publique qui est
un commandant de compagnie de CRS ou le
commandant de l'escadron gendarmerie
mobile utilise les moyens adéquates pour
permettre les évacuation de cette place
ou
également de de fin de mettre fin à
des cassages de vitrines de mobilier
urbains et même de notre de des
établissements publics voilà et sur sur
la plaque parisienne donc on a déjà eu
pendant ces manifestations sur la loi
retraite on a eu ces problématiques
voilà
donc le sMMO on essaye il les essayent
de le mettre on essaye de le mettre en
place on a juste monsieur le rapporteur
qui souhaite avoir une précision par
rapport à ce que vous venez de dire à
l'instant oui j'ai bien compris la
confusion des rôles que vous indiquez
mais expliquez peut-être à la commission
d'enquête en quoi c'est une
problématique réelle pour vous en quoi
ça pose un problème y compris
opérationnel qu'il y ait une telle
confusion des fonctions des rôles à
l'occasion d'un certain nombre de
rassemblement et est-ce que vous avez
des exemples précis à nous donner y
compris récent s'il vous plaît
alors
les rôles ils sont en simples ils sont
ils sont dans le code de procédure
pénale donc en fait il y a il y a
l'autorité civile qui doit donner comme
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure les
objectifs à atteindre il y a le
commandant de la force publique qui est
lui le spécialiste du maintien de
l'ordre et qui sait lui comment il doit
mettre en œuvre les moyens adaptés s'il
doit utiliser les canons à eau s'il doit
utiliser des grenades s'il doit utiliser
des bons offensifs ou des charges voilà
c'est c'est c'est le commandant de la
force publique qui doit mettre en place
ça voilà après bien sûr toutes les
toutes les sommations d'usage voilà et
sur la sur la plaque parisienne avec
certains certaines pays comme on les
appelle voilà les compagnies
républicaines de sécurité
ont ont des soucis voilà donc et ce qui
crée également donc une certaine
confusion dans les ordres reçus et les
ordres qu'on va qu'on va mettre en place
merci beaucoup monsieur Jacob
merci monsieur le Président à ça va être
compliqué de répondre à toutes les
questions de Monsieur le Député parce
que je j'ai pas forcément les
informations notamment sur sur le
financement des groupuscules qui
viennent sur les sur les manifestations
par contre sur la structuration et ça
répondrait également à la question de
sainte Soline et de la prévisibilité
non c'est pas prévisible c'est pas
prévisible parce que c'est
particulièrement complexe le mouvement
Black Bloc tout à bord il faut savoir
mais vous le savez que le mouvement
Black Bloc est composé d'une multitude
de mouvances
issue principalement des milieux
d'activistes du tragot anarchiste
libertaire altermondialiste antifa entre
autres et que ce n'est pas une
organisation structurée je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure il n'y a pas de
hiérarchie établie il n'y a pas de
leader et donc
c'est difficile à surveiller comme
mouvement d'autant que là aussi je le
disais tout à l'heure il y a la question
de comment anticiper leur action
notamment via tous les échanges qui
peuvent avoir sur les réseaux sociaux
sur les messageries cryptées qui
nécessitent à renforcement de la lutte
contre la cybercriminalité ça en fait
partie et que
il suffit à tous ces groupuscules d'un
seul appel sur ces réseaux là pour que
il convergent sur un point commun pour
agir donc ça c'est toute la difficulté
de la prévisibilité du mouvement Black
Bloc et de comment ils vont agir la
deuxième c'est que sur ces mêmes réseaux
ce qui démontre que le financement n'est
quand même pas un financement
occulte qui serait
donnée par certains organismes ou
associations ou collectif et autres
c'est que les engins qu'ils utilisent
tout ce qui est engin incendiaire
mortier d'artifice et tout ça très
souvent on découvre des armes
artisanales c'est à dire des armes
qu'ils ont fabriqué eux-mêmes au moyen
de ce qu'ils ont pu trouver là aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux donc en fait chacun
prépare son petit truc dans son coin
puis tout le monde se rejoint et puis
après chacun utilise les moyens qu'il a
qu'il a mis à sa disposition
sur les violences policières et là je
pense que on sera tous unanime oui la
parole publique est dangereuse quand
elle véhicule un message un slogan qui
vise à dire qu'il y a des violences
policières et ça donne une certaine
légitimité à ces gens-là et à ceux qui
s'agrègent au mouvement des Black Blocs
c'est à dire la part radicale de
manifestants qui expriment quelque chose
par la violence et moi je les
manifestants ne vont pas de la colère à
la violence ça c'est pas vrai il y a les
manifestants qui expriment une colère
pacifiste et puis il y a les casseurs
qui viennent pour la violence sont pas
les deux même population
il y en a un petit peu les plus radicaux
de manifestants mais c'est très à la
marge mais ceux qui viennent exprimer
une colère le font de manière pacifique
en plus sont des syndicalises donc
j'ai participé à l'ensemble des
manifestations depuis le mois de janvier
moi j'ai pas été gazé j'ai pas eu de
problème j'ai manifesté sereinement
pacifiquement jusqu'au bout et il y a eu
des heures mais j'étais pas de ce qui
était dans les affrontements avec mes
collègues donc on a bien à faire un
groupe très particulier de personnes qui
expriment autre chose qu'une
revendication et qu'il exprime par la
violence
donc sur la violence policière oui je
dénonce avec force malheureusement les
propos de certaines personnalités
publiques politiques qui véhiculent ce
message de violence policière et de
rappeler la loi la police utilise dans
le cadre d'un rétablissement des
troubles à l'ordre public une violence
légitime je pense que c'est utile à
rappeler vous le disiez très justement
ce ne sont pas les policiers qui vont
provoquer à la violence sur les
manifestations ils sont là pour mettre
un terme aux troubles à l'ordre public
et pas pour les provoquer et de garantir
que des manifestants puissent exprimer
leur revendication de manière en toute
sécurité tout comme de garantir à
n'importe quelle personne d'aller et
venir sur la voie publique pendant une
manifestation y compris en toute
sécurité
[Musique]
sur le maintien de l'ordre notamment en
fin de manifestation et votre question
de confirmer s'il y a un besoin
d'information de communication renforcée
pour les manifestations j'ai répondu
tout à l'heure oui il est nécessaire de
renforcer cette information et cette
communication à destination des
manifestants pacifistes pour éviter
qu'il se trouve à nouveau confronté sur
des théâtres à des théâtres de violence
je rejoins également mon collègue par
rapport à l'expérience de terrain
malheureusement c'est pas propre au
maintien de l'ordre et c'est pas faute
de le dire là où il faut le dire dans
nos instances c'est que on a on souffre
dans la police nationale d'un problème
de retour d'expérience c'est à dire
qu'on ne prend pas assez en compte
l'expérience de terrain des policiers on
nous fixe des objectifs et on est là
pour les conduire bien évidemment mais
quand on est confronté à un problème sur
le terrain on devrait nous écouter en
disant voilà ok on a des objectifs il
faut qu'on les conduise mais attention
sur le terrain ce que vous nous demandez
de faire et bien on peut pas le faire
dans tel condition et ça malheureusement
on manque de ce qu'on appelle chez nous
d'un rétex régulier sur quel que soit la
mission d'ailleurs et notamment des
réunions de briefing alors ça il y en a
mais des réunions de débriefing surtout
pour avoir le retour des professionnels
de terrain que nous sommes de façon à ce
qu'on puisse adapter l'action de la
police et notamment en maintien de
l'ordre
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner
l'un ou l'autre exemple qui permettent
de de comprendre
pas il y a des spécialistes autour de la
table moi je suis pas je suis pas de
formation CRS mais un sujet qui touche
particulièrement les policiers de
sécurité publique quand vous êtes
confronté à la mort un accident de la
route une personne décédée que vous êtes
confronté à une personne qui s'est
suicidée
vous êtes quand même un peu seul pour
digérer ce que vous avez vécu ça c'est
d'abord le retour d'expérience
professionnelle ensuite vous pouvez
avoir des problématiques d'intervention
dans les quartiers difficiles souvent on
doit intervenir dans des quartiers
difficiles on nous demande d'aller faire
de la lutte notamment contre les trafics
de stupéfiants et il se passe ce qui se
passe en termes de médiatisation de
l'action de police bien on fait du
contrôle officiel on fait des contrôles
abusifs on est toujours en train de
contrôler les mêmes personnes sur un
endroit déterminé mais peut-être
peut-être que si on demandait aux
collègues comment il voit
leur mission au quotidien pour conduire
les objectifs qu'on leur fixe peut-être
qu'on aurait des situations sur
lesquelles nous ne serions pas
confrontés et qui ne feraient pas
l'objet d'une médiatisation comme on la
connaît je peux donner un exemple très
précis aujourd'hui les collègues
n'interviennent plus ou pas ou peu sur
alors vous allez me dire c'est pas bien
grave mais ça pourrit la vie au
quotidien de la population les trafics
de cigarettes aux abords des gares
moi je transite par une gare connue pour
cela tous les jours vous avez des
trafics de cigarettes en tout genre vous
avez les collègues qui sont à 50 mètres
et à 100 mètres et ils vont pas
intervenir et pourquoi parce que vous
avez des rapports divers et variés qui
disent que voilà à la gare du Nord si ça
sept personnes sur 10 d'origine
étrangère sont susceptibles de faire
l'objet d'un contrôle d'identité sauf
que quand vous prenez les personnes qui
trafiquent les cigarettes sur cette gare
malheureusement on est confronté à des
personnes d'origine étrangère donc à un
moment donné on est confronté à des
situations où on est spectateur on
n'intervient pas et que écouter un peu
plus les policiers de terrain sur leur
expérience sur les problèmes auxquels
ils ont confronté permettra peut-être
j'ai pas la prétention de dire que c'est
la solution mais en tous les cas de
prendre en compte le retour d'expérience
de terrain pour adapter les missions de
police peut peut-être aussi une solution
pour améliorer l'améliorer l'efficacité
de l'action policière
préciser aussi en point de vue sur le
schéma national du maintien de l'ordre
quand même savoir que la direction
centrale des CRS n'a pas été associée à
l'élaboration de ce document
on est quand même c'est une direction
qui est spécialiste qui n'a pas du tout
été consultée dans la rédaction de ce
document je pense un élément aussi qui
est important qui doit qui doit être
pris en compte alors en CRS on a la
chance nous de faire des rétex des
retours d'expérience il y en a eu un il
y a un mois à peu près sur la commune de
Vélizy dans le cas du génoise qu'on
appelle les Journées Nationales d'action
et à chaque brosse généralement grave
opération les CRS sont capables de se
réunir et de faire des textes et de
suite tous les points sont détaillés
avec l'analyse des recommandations c'est
des choses qui sont qui sont
intéressantes parce que sur le sur le
dernier on a pu en discuter sur le
devenir des textes par exemple on voit
notamment l'histoire des moyens
l'histoire de coordination des forces
sur Paris donc si vous pouvez vous
procurer ce document c'est intéressant
parce que c'est en tout cas ça reste
c'est fait très très régulièrement
je pense un élément qui peut être appuyé
qui peut être appuyé dessus concernant
votre question sur la là la mise à
distance il a mobilité enfin pour moi
c'est pas un problème parce que la mise
à distance en tout cas les CRS se sont
toujours adaptées dans le cas de la
doctrine d'emploi il y a toujours une
évolution on a pu le voir notamment
grâce au retour d'expérience qu'on sait
faire soit des manifestations vous avez
le la mise à distance qui qui est faite
pas des compagnie traditionnelles et a
été mis en place
se fait trois quatre manifestations ce
qu'on appelle des GTD c'est des groupes
tactiques temporaires qui sont mis en
place vous avez deux unités de CRS qui
suivent dans des rues parallèles la
manifestation donc ça c'est c'est des
choses qui sont mis en place on va avoir
un petit peu voir le retour parce que
c'est aussi enfin au niveau de
personnalité des choses à améliorer
parce qu'on faut pas faire aux collègues
10 km 12 km et après intervenir c'est
que c'est compliqué mais c'est des
choses qui sont mis en place parce que
le fait de garder à distance et la
mobilité pour moi c'est pas
contradictoire mais il faut aussi se
coordonner avec les autres forces
notamment son souvent sur la plaque
parisienne ça peut être en complément
des SCI des bravesm ou autre parce que
les premiers le premier rideau ça doit
rester ça doit rester les forces mobiles
qui sont qui sont vraiment spécialisés
et rompu à ce genre d'entraînement à
plus de 20 20 jours de formation par an
voilà mais en tout cas on s'adapter par
rapport à ça je vous dis le groupe
d'appui temporaire c'est une chose qui
est développée et qui est quand même
intéressantes dans le cadre d'une
réaction qui doit être rapide ça c'est
une chose ensuite en revenant un peu sur
Sainte Soline je pense enfin vous avez
eu lecture un peu de du rapport du
général et de la préfète et je pense que
la plage photo est si intéressante
lorsqu'on voit des gens viennent sur une
manifestation avec une meuleuse avec un
chalumeau par exemple ça on dit un peu
avec le avec le niveau donc c'est vrai
que les deux rapports puissent la
planche photo c'est quand même assez
significatif et permettre un peu
d'orienter un peu sur sur les événements
ensuite sur le terme violence policière
je reviendrai enfin ce que je disais
tout à l'heure on prend en bulle oui
c'est une volonté de de certaines
personnalités en fait de ne pas
légitimer l'action de l'autorité comme
on dit ça on tente d'affaiblir un peu et
c'est malheureusement c'est ce qui est
repris un peu partout notamment dans les
médias ou autre lorsqu'il y a une petite
affaire on parle tout de suite de
violence policière sauf que l'usage de
la force c'est le policier qui ont
dispose ensuite est-ce qu'elle est bonne
ou pas bonne il y a toujours des
enquêtes il y a pas de souci les
policiers je pense qu'on est les plus
contrôlés il y a ces GPN et bien souvent
on se rend compte qu'à la fin il y a eu
un usage proportionné de la force voilà
mais quand on prend 2 secondes d'image
qu'on ne monte pas l'avant qu'on monte
pas là après c'est là où c'est dommage
ou parfois ce qu'on dit les caméras
piétons peuvent aussi parfois servir à
dédouaner l'accent des forces de l'ordre
est-ce que l'administration ne fait pas
c'est nous on joue ce rôle mais ce
serait bien aussi des fois que ben voilà
lorsqu'on accuse à tort les forces de
l'ordre qu'on puisse aussi produire des
images montrant le début et la fin de
l'action je pense ça peut être des
choses qui sont qui sont aussi
intéressantes par rapport à ça mais je
reviens un peu sur le
sur la mise à distance voilà pour moi
c'est enfin c'est pas du tout une
contradiction on sait faire et les CRS
se sont toujours adaptés
je voudrais rajouter quelque chose
concernant ce qu'a dit Monsieur Jacob
sur les Black Blocs les Black Blocs en
fait bon comme il a dit c'est très
hétéroclite mais on a des gens en fait
de tout de tout de toute nature on peut
de et on a on a pu remarquer maintenant
énormément de personnels féminins qui
font partie de ces groupes Black Bloc
le Black Bloc est composé on va dire de
2 il y a ceux qui vont casser il y a
ceux qui vont protéger et on a pu se
rendre compte vous vous avez vu dans les
les images les black-box se protègent
toujours derrière une bâche ou des
parapluies donc ces bâches sont souvent
tenues par des personnels féminins pour
protéger l'action violente des des
on va dire des des intervenants des en
fait c'est des professionnels de la
casse nous on les appelle et c'est des
professionnels de la bagarre ils veulent
en découdre contre la première des
choses c'est ils veulent en découdre
envers les forces de l'ordre ils veulent
des coudre enfin ils veulent se battre
sur les forces de l'ordre ça il faut ça
il faut que que
qu'on le sache on a connu ce phénomène
il y a déjà il y a déjà 30 ans c'était
les les hooligans au Parc des Princes
les les c'est pseudo supporters venez
pour se battre entre eux et se battre
contre les forces de l'ordre et là en
fait on avec ses gros muscu actuellement
c'est c'est la même chose qui est en
train de se de se recréer on trouve
voilà alors
la dissimulation la dissimulation vous
on peut le voir il porte toujours des
lunettes des grosses lunettes de ski des
masques maintenant le des masques alors
des masques qui peuvent qui peuvent
protéger du gaz lacrymogène
ils ont toujours un k-way dessus qui est
très léger donc très facile à enlever et
à jeter
et donc ces personnes ces personnes sont
très très mobiles alors là tout à
l'heure je disais dans le parcours de la
manifestation également ce qu'il
faudrait protéger également c'est ces
axes les axes métro parce qu'en fait
dans le dans les dans le parcours de la
manifestation on va fermer le les axes
les axes de métro ou de transport en
commun au début de la manifestation et
en fin de manifestation mais on ne ferme
pas les axes
tout le long de la manifestation et on a
pu se rendre compte d'après les
renseignements qu'on a que ces
groupuscules arrivent à
pénétrer la manifestation en fait via
ses axes voilà via ces axes de métro ils
sortent des métros ils se retrouvent à
ils sortent 10 par 10 ou 20 par 20 de
chaque de chaque métro et ce qui forme
en fait le bloc voilà
il y a quelques années on avait trouvé
on a trouvé la délégation des CRS Paris
qui était sous la direction du du
commissaire divisionnaire Pouchin
Olivier Pouchet avait trouvé cette
stratégie de vraiment canaliser les
accès
canaliser les accès à ces manifestations
et dès que le bourloup le groupe se
constituait en fait c'était de le comme
on dit chez nous dans notre jargon le
casser en fait pour qu'il ne puisse pas
se constituer et en venir à la violence
avec avec les forces de l'ordre voilà
donc voilà le les Black Blocs en fait
voilà je veux dire c'est c'est vraiment
très hétéroclite
il peut y avoir des gens on va dire
comme nous comme nous des gens de de
quartier sensibles mais également des
gens comme nous et on en trouve de plus
en plus également voilà lors des
interpellations
merci pour ces précisions alors avant de
d'ouvrir
aux collègues en termes de questions
donc n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs chers
collègues à vous signaler si vous avez
des questions simplement un point sur
lequel je voudrais revenir vous avez
fait ce distinguer très pertinent entre
manifestation autorisée donc déclarer
autorisé et par ailleurs manifestation
interdite question sans doute très naïve
de ma part mais je pense que c'est
important quand même d'avoir votre
regard là dessus
est-il possible d'empêcher des
manifestations interdites ou est-ce que
on est face à des difficultés énormes
puisque vous vous y faisiez référence si
vous regardez sainte Soline était
interdite la dernière manifestation que
nous avons élast connue pas plus tard
que que samedi dernier celle-ci aussi en
Maurienne était interdite
pourtant elles ont eu lieu c'est à dire
que il y a eu à la fois des manifestants
pour un certain nombre pacifique et puis
hélas une nouvelle fois une une montée
de violence de la part d'éléments
extrêmement radicalisés
effectivement faut faire la notion mais
enfin on peut ça dépend ça va pas être
tout le théâtre dans une ville ça peut
être un peu plus facile à gérer parce
qu'on arrive identifier quand ils
arrivent ou autre et c'est à dire c'est
dès le départ lorsqu'on va 10 ou 15
personnes qui arrivent c'est là où il
faut le contrôler vers baliser par
rapport à la retraitement les dissiper
par contre en zone rurale c'est un peu
plus difficile mais on le voit on met
quelque part la manifestation est
interdite tout le monde le sait les
arrêter mais on laisse s'installer les
gens alors soit dans des terrains privés
ou là c'est difficile d'intervenir où il
y a des gens qui qui viennent il faut
encore moins illégal mais quand on peut
constater globalement on les laisse
quand même s'installer que ce soit sur
un terrain privé ou autre on laisse les
gens s'installer donc on sait le
lendemain malgré la diffusion
s'interdite ils vont être présents
rurales c'est peut-être plus difficile à
gérer quand on urbaine ou lorsque les
gens arrivent comme c'était fait un
moment sur les gilets jaunes 10 15 bah
il faut tout de suite les contrôler
mettre un nombre de forces conséquent
contrôlées et puis il va baiser faire
partir mais aussi une volonté derrière
parce que des fois donc de volonté c'est
à dire que les instructions sont pas
tout de suite donnés lorsqu'ils font
intervenir ce qui fait qu'on laisse
monter un peu les gens ça se rassemblent
quand ils arrivent à 10 15 20 vous
pouvez gérer ensuite quand ça arrive
sans 200 300 c'est un peu plus difficile
mais on peut il faut on peut agir
différemment sur un groupement qui est
méfaits qui interdite par rapport à une
association qui autorisé c'est beaucoup
plus facile ça qui interdite parce que
dès le départ tu les Asté son prix mais
je pense que ce soit sur le début ça lui
manifestation autorisant toutes les
questions de volonté de décision que les
instructions se donnaient aux forces de
l'ordre et souvent c'est un peu là où le
bas blesse
oui je vous en prie et je voudrais
rajouter donc quand la manifestation est
interdite je dis pas je dis bien
manifestation est interdite ça devient
un attroupement et l'attroupement dans
le code de procédure pénale est
considéré comme un délit voilà donc
quand on dit voilà donc on pourrait
c'est vrai engager immédiatement la
force publique et les forces de l'ordre
pour faire évacuer les gens qui qui
essayent de pénétrer quelque part où
c'est interdit
merci beaucoup je vais passer la parole
aux collègues donc j'ai eu une première
demande de prise de parole madame Maxime
donc je vais tout de suite vous la
passer ensuite j'ai madame Diaz ensuite
monsieur taverne ici il y en a d'autres
donc Madame Maxime je vous en prie merci
monsieur le président madame messieurs
merci de votre présence alors moi je
voulais commencer par une première chose
c'est que la liberté des élus aussi de
venir aussi témoigner vérifier et c'est
ce qu'ils peuvent faire aussi lors de
manifestations déclarer ou non c'est
aussi leur leur fonction à des moments
de pouvoir être témoins observés ce qui
se passe enfin moi j'avais ce préalable
là notamment quand ça s'est passé à
Sainte Soline ou à la manifestation de
ce week-end je voulais revenir moi sur
plusieurs choses sur
vous faisiez le distinguo entre
manifestation interdite et autorisée et
il y a un troisième cas de figure donc
on n'a pas abordé c'est les
manifestations que j'appelle spontanées
qui sont plutôt catégorisées comme
sauvages ou non déclarés qui elle
n'entraîne pas d'attraction dans leur
participation et je voulais
[Musique]
beaucoup de jeunes qui étaient là pour
manifester qui ne connaît pas forcément
d'actes en tout cas c'est ce que nous
disent les chiffres que de sortie de
commissariat et quand vous parliez des
bus et des dispositifs de proximité j'ai
le souvenir aussi de ce soir-là de bus
de panier à salade remplie de
manifestants qui ne trouvaient même plus
de place dans les commissariats
tellement il y avait d'arrestations et
derrière pas grand chose donc il y a des
gens qui n'avaient qui sont sortis sans
100 poursuite qu'on passait de
nombreuses heures en garde à vue moi je
voulais savoir si les consignes par
exemple étaient adaptées ce soir là
ensuite j'ai une autre question qui est
en lien plus avec la doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre et quand vous dites
que les Black Blocs veulent en découdre
avec les forces de l'ordre ça je sais
pas ce que je conteste mais du coup
j'interroge les modifications de la
doctrine qui est maintenant d'aller
beaucoup plus au contact ce qui était
pas forcément toujours le cas mais en
tout cas une présence beaucoup plus
rapprochée et vous nous dites aussi que
ce phénomène est européen ça je suis
bien d'accord avec vous mais comment on
explique que par exemple la violence se
déploie pas exactement la même façon et
par la même intensité dans les autres
pays européen et enfin je voulais votre
avis aussi sur ce que vient de produire
l'ONU les experts de l'ONU sur les
alertes qui font sur la question
justement du maintien de l'ordre qui
dans leur rapport peuvent alerter sur
des inquiétudes sur l'usage excessif de
la force sur notamment la façon dont on
travaille la bravène qui a été au cœur
de beaucoup de d'articles beaucoup de de
d'intérêt en tout cas dans le dans la
vie politique et sur le nombre de
blessés de leur gravité qui augmente
aussi suite à ces opérations c'est un
rapport de l'ONU qui est sorti en fin de
semaine dernière qui est qui s'inquiète
qui s'adar de ce qui s'est passé pendant
cette mobilisation des retraites et
enfin sur la question de de
la liberté des responsables politiques
aussi de qualifier aussi ce qu'ils
estiment à la fois des faits
parce que c'est que vous interprétez
sûrement différent mais différemment
mais je pense que nous avons aussi nous
sommes dans un pays où nous avons aussi
le droit en tant que personnalité
politique de qualifier et de mettre des
mots sur ce que nous pouvons voir et
j'avais une dernière chose sur je finis
vite sur la question des manifestations
ou par les beaucoup de dislocations
c'est à dire des fins mais ce qu'on a
observé quand même pendant le mouvement
des retraites c'est des interventions
des unités de CRS ou la bravème assez
tôt dans les manifestations en coeur de
cortège avec des services d'ordre
d'organisation syndicale connu et
reconnus qui ont été
qui ont subi ces interventions
policières et je j'aimerais avoir votre
avis là-dessus parce que j'estime que
enfin je me questionne quand même sur
ces organisations syndicales qu'on
connaît avec qui vous travaillez dans
ces grandes manifestations
nous avons des images où on voit des du
maintien de l'ordre sur ces
organisations syndicales et leur service
d'ordre
merci beaucoup je vois que Monsieur
Jacob non
je vais vous laisser réagir donc
monsieur nassimato c'est ça
oui alors moi je voudrais
alors le maintien de l'ordre comme je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure le maintien
de l'ordre à la française est réputé
mondialement
[Musique]
alors après on prend beaucoup beaucoup
en
exergue le maintien de l'ordre fait en
Allemagne il faut savoir qu'en Allemagne
les les manifestants sont beaucoup plus
respectueux des forces de l'ordre voilà
il n'y a que très rarement des violences
lors de manifestations en Allemagne mais
quand il y a des violences
dans des manifestations en Allemagne
les Allemands
le maintien de l'ordre à l'allemande et
se fait par le nombre c'est-à-dire que
on multiplie énormément énormément les
effectifs et on va au contact physique
qui qui amène des blessés côté
manifestants et également côté policier
en France on préfère le le
je dois dire le savoir tenir à distance
et manifestations en utilisant les
moyens intermédiaires comme comme nous
les avons
et sur les manifestations que qu'on a vu
qu'on a vu sur sur Paris lors des
retraites ou même ailleurs
on peut se rendre compte également de la
résilience qu'on fait preuve nos
collègues des forces de l'ordre et des
compagnies républicains de sécurité et
de gendarmes mobiles avant de d'utiliser
d'utiliser les les moyens les moyens
intermédiaires voire même les canons à
eau voilà ça a été le on va dire même là
je parle sous le sous le contrôle de mes
deux collègues Joan et Monsieur Jacob
où ça a été le mot c'était résilienté
vraiment vraiment tenir
avant d'utiliser les les moyens les
moyens dont on dispose
pour revenir donc et aux manifestations
et aux interpellations qui a eu qui a eu
lors de ces manifestations spontanées
comme on appelle mais qui ont été quand
même
interdites par le préfet de police donc
voilà quand il y a une manifestation
spontanées il y a interpellation est
mise à disposition de d'un officier de
police judiciaire dans un commissariat
après je vais laisser parler ma collègue
qui est officier de police judiciaire et
qui pourra peut-être vous vous en dire
un peu davantage là dessus je vous en
prie madame Lecocq et puis ensuite
monsieur Jacob a demandé la parole
oui donc pour répondre à la question de
Madame sur ces 9 personnes qui ont été
poursuivies seulement sur les 280 et
quelques il faut savoir que la personne
est présentée à l'OPJ l'OPG en fonction
des raisons plausibles en fait
prendre la décision de l'emplacement en
garde à vue ou non ce placement en garde
à vue il est pas anodin il est par
rapport au fait qu'il lui sont remontés
notamment par l'affiche de l'agent
interpellateur ensuite il y a le temps
de l'enquête le temps de l'enquête
permet de déterminer à charger à
décharge ce qui a pu commettre telle ou
telle personne
il permet aussi de savoir de connaître
et de voir l'exploitation des vidéos des
caméras piétons de procéder aux
auditions et ainsi de suite ce n'est pas
du ressort de l'OPGI de décider des
poursuites c'est le parquet donc le PJ
rencontre pour tel investigation et pour
telle personne de son enquête seul le
parquet est en charge de
déterminer s'il doit prolonger la
personne s'il doit donner des poursuites
ou non donc effectivement le parquet ce
jour-là madame peut être a décidé que
seulement 9 personnes sur 280 et
quelques devaient être poursuivi en
justice mais cela n'est pas du travail
du ressort de la police
merci beaucoup madame Le Coq monsieur
Jacob
oui merci
sur la doctrine du contact donc vous
parliez
il faut quand même rappeler que le
nouveau schéma de maintien de l'Orne n'a
pas retiré le principe du maintien de
l'ordre de distance de garder à distance
il a dit les deux et le mon collègue
Jean-Paul le disait très justement on
s'adapte à la situation à laquelle on
est confronté sur le terrain et je
rappellerai que ce qui ce qui distingue
d'une manifestation déclarée d'une
manifestation non déclarée ou d'un
mouvement spontané c'est qu'une
manifestation déclarée vous le savez est
préparé elle est préparée en amont avec
les forces de sécurité avec les services
d'ordre des organisations syndicales et
que les services d'or des organisations
syndicales pendant la manifestation sont
en contact direct radio avec les forces
de sécurité alors c'est beaucoup plus
facile c'est sûr pour nous de gérer dans
le meilleur conditions un maintien de
l'ordre sur une manifestation déclarée
que sur une manifestation qui ne l'est
pas surtout quand on ne sait pas
vraiment comment ça va se dérouler qui
va venir et là on en a pas parlé
notamment sur les manifestations
interdites mais il y a tout le travail
durant ces alignement territorial qui
est là pour nous indiquer
potentiellement qui va venir quel risque
qu'on encourt et comment on doit
organiser le maintien de l'autre puisque
en général sur les manifestations
interdites et bien on fait un peu au
juger le nombre de forces de sécurité
qu'on doit mobiliser mais sans jamais
vraiment savoir à quoi on va être
confronté sur la parole politique il
m'appartient pas et je serais bien mal
placé d'ailleurs de faire quelques
commentaires que ce soit bien évidemment
que le politique a tout ta voix dans des
mouvements sociaux et de porter une
parole publique encore faut-il qu'il ne
l'utilise pas pour inciter les personnes
à se confronter à la police ou à la
gendarmerie ou au fort de sécurité en
général comme j'ai pu le constater
moi-même sur certaines manifestations
donc bien évidemment que le politique a
c'est le propre de notre démocratie et
il est pas question en tant que
fonctionnaire de police républicain de
remettre un seul instant en cause la
participation de nos élus sur des
mouvements sociaux et de porter une
parole politique mais je pense qu'il y a
certaines limites à ne pas dépasser dans
les propos qui je le disais tout à
l'heure attise une légitimité à se
confronter aux forces de sécurité
juste sur ce point précis est-ce que
vous pourriez être un petit peu plus
explicite c'est-à-dire que vous avez
vous-même pu constater de telles faits
pouvez-vous indiquer lesquels j'ai pu
les voir comme de nombreux collègues par
rapport à des présences de politiques
sur certaines manifestations ou les
propos n'étaient pas à l'apaisement et
plutôt à attiser et je suis désolé mais
je suis syndicaliste mais je suis aussi
fongaire de police et vous comprendrez
que devoir de réserve m'impose de ne pas
citer préciser précisément des des faits
et des voilà des personnalités
politiques en tous les cas je je je
me réserve le droit de de ne pas
répondre à précisément à cette à cette
question monsieur le Président
sur les violences de plus en plus fortes
qu'on aurait en France
on a eu il y a quelques années des
manifestations en Angleterre
écoutez entre utiliser des grenades
lacrymogènes en France et me faire
charger par des policiers à cheval avec
des grands bâtons et à fracasser les
jambes des manifestants comme on a pu le
connaître en Angleterre je pense que on
peut pas considérer que la police sur le
maintien de l'ordre et la plus violente
en Europe en tous les cas je ne le pense
pas qu'on essaye de trouver des moyens
alternatifs pour maîtriser des théâtres
de violence sur des manifestations qui
peut éviter des dommages collatéraux
bien évidemment je le disais aussi tout
à l'heure on n'est pas là pour venir
fracasser les manifestants
et je rappelle là aussi que
historiquement le maintien de l'ordre à
la française c'est de privilégier les
dommages mobiliers au dommages humains
et c'est ce qui fait que le maintien de
l'ordre français a été depuis toujours
reconnu comme un des meilleurs maintiens
de l'ordre dans le monde donc je tenais
à le à le préciser
écoutez je crois avoir fait le tour sur
les consignes non il n'y a pas de
consigne particulier mon collègue l'a
très bien dit tout à l'heure sur le les
différentes manifestations contre la
réforme des retraites on nous a demandé
de faire preuve de la plus grande
résilience dans la gestion des maintiens
de l'ordre donc il y a pas de consigne
qui viseraient aller réprimer
systématiquement des personnes qui
manifesteraient un peu de de vie et sans
forcément faire usage de la violence
merci beaucoup monsieur Carrero juste
une précision c'est pas un rapport de
l'ONU c'est cette personne cette
rapporteur spéciaux de l'ONU mais s'ils
sont encore aucun code enfin ce sont pas
ils ont pas comment dire exprimé ce sont
pas exprimés au nom de l'ONU c'est cette
expert c'est important c'est pas l'ONU
c'est cette experts qui sont pas cette
notion
[Musique]
merci beaucoup il y avait une demande de
prise de parole de Madame Diaz donc je
vous la passe ensuite je taverne et
ensuite monsieur madness
merci monsieur le Président bonsoir
madame et Messieurs moi je voulais
commencer par vous remercier pour
remercier pour ce que vous faites et
vous remercier pour votre franchise qui
me semble correspondre à la majorité des
images que la majorité des Français a vu
et c'est vrai que en fonction des
lectures que nous pouvons avoir ou en
fonction des auditions que nous avons
entendues c'est vrai que parfois on se
demandait si on parlait bien du même
sujet je vais vous prendre quelques
exemples vous avez évoqué la
structuration des Black Blocs on a pu
entendre parfois que finalement il y
avait pas tellement de structures
c'était plutôt des personnes tout à fait
lambda qui seraient emporté par un élan
arriver d'ondes et vous vous avez quand
même indiqué que dans la plupart des cas
il s'agissait donc d'organisation que
ces organisations étaient préparées vous
avez même évoqué c'est la première fois
que je l'entends la question du stage de
formation que suivrait certains
Black Bloc vous parlez de leur
organisation en matière de communication
de messagerie cryptées etc
vous soulignez et c'est très intéressant
que l'augmentation des violences n'est
pas historique comme certains veulent
faire le croire pour tenter de peut-être
baisser en termes de gravité l'effet qui
sont reprochés à certains
individus et vous avez même si vous avez
gardé votre
mis beaucoup de réserve vous avez quand
même indiqué que la présence d'élus
visait dans certains cas à rendre
dangereuse les opérations et à
galvaniser voire à légitimer c'est
délinquant moi j'ai deux questions à
vous poser s'il vous plaît
la première c'est comment vous expliquer
ce décalage qui peut avoir est-ce qu'il
s'agit d'une absence de prise de
conscience ou alors est-ce que il y a
des gens qui sont dans le déni qui ne
sont pas avec vous sur le terrain et
vous qui êtes au premier loge moi j'ai
plus tendance à penser que c'est vous
qui avez la meilleure perception et la
deuxième question que je voudrais vous
poser c'est vous nous avez décrit un
certain nombre de préconisations
donc je vais j'en ai noté quelques-unes
qu'il faudrait faire plus de rétexte de
débriefing parce que ça se fait dans par
exemple chez les CS chez les CRS mais ça
se fait pas dans tous les services de
police donc pourquoi vous avez fait la
proposition de l'installation de
l'instauration des bus mobiles ça me
semble pas très difficile à mettre en
place la question des traceurs ADN
chimiques pour ma part c'est la première
fois que j'entends un chauffe c'est une
bonne idée la mise en place de caméra de
piétons généralisée ça se fait alors
pourquoi ça ne se fait pas partout là
c'est pareil ça ne m'apparaît pas être à
une montagne technologique à surmonter
et enfin je me pose la question pourquoi
en effet quand il s'agit d'une
manifestation interdite on n'engage pas
la procédure de de dispersion en tout
cas d'interdiction de cette
manifestation donc ce sont des questions
assez nombreuses mais c'est vrai que je
pense que ça serait important que vous
puissiez les éclaircir parce que je vous
garantis que dans l'opinion ou dans
certains judistes certains intervenants
qu'on a entendu ou dans certaines
lectures que l'on peut faire les choses
qui semblent évidentes que vous avez
décrites ne sont pas évidentes pour tout
le monde je vous remercie
qui souhaite commencer à répondre oui
monsieur Jacob je vous en prie
je vous remercie madame je vais pas
reprendre tout ce que j'ai pu aborder
précédemment mais juste vous dire
qu'effectivement peut-être qu'on manque
de communication pédagogique à
destination de la population pour
expliquer et pourtant c'est pas faute
d'avoir de plus en plus de reportages
sur la police la gendarmerie dans les
médias mais je pense que peut-être la
population une certaine population en
tous les cas qui participe aux
manifestations ne sont peut-être pas
suffisamment
informés sur ce qu'est le maintien de
l'ordre que nous pratiquons en France
comment on le pratique on a des
spécialistes des CRS ils l'ont dit tout
à l'heure ils font régulièrement des
stages j'ai pratiqué le maintien de
l'ordre en début de carrière et je peux
vous dire que on est les premiers
concernés à expérimenter le gaz
lacrymogène en formation pour savoir
l'effet que ça fait quand on est sur
donc on sait ce que ça fait c'est pas
anodin utiliser du gaz lacrymogène et on
s'est pertinemment puisque on est formé
dans ce cadre là et je pense qu'E
effectivement il y a peut-être un défaut
de pédagogie de communication à
destination de la population sur comment
on fait du maintien de l'ordre en France
alors sans bien évidemment révélés les
différentes pratiques que l'on peut
avoir pour pour canaliser des théâtres
d'affrontements mais en tous les cas
peut-être faire un peu plus de de
diffusion de de pédagogie d'expérience
que l'on peut avoir sur sur les
manifestations
sur le reste du matériel vous avez
synthétisé mon intervention de tout à
l'heure je pense que c'est des sujets
qui sont de toute façon déjà portées au
ministère de l'Intérieur certaines
d'entre elles sont déjà étudiées
peut-être peut-être que je me trompe il
me semble que des expériences ont même
été conduites en Mo en matière de
l'ordre
à confirmer mais en tous les cas voilà
ce sont des propositions qu'on aimerait
bien voir
concrétiser rapidement on a eu je le
disais la loi en 2016 on a eu la période
des gilets jaunes pendant 18 mois on a
eu six mois de manifestations contre les
retraites il est pas
il est pas du tout
impossible que nous ayons dans les mois
à venir de nouveau mouvement sociaux et
je j'espère que non pour mes collègues
déjà parce que ils sont mis à
contribution depuis maintenant beaucoup
beaucoup d'années sur différentes
missions et c'est vrai que l'apaisement
serait quand même bien mais on est aussi
syndicaliste et il y a certains sujets
que nous portons et qui pour le moment
attend de réponse
du gouvernement notamment donc il est
pas impossible qu'il y ait des
mouvements sociaux ça fait partie aussi
de l'expression démocratique de notre
pays et il faut il faut aussi le saluer
et qu'ils savent il serait effectivement
bien que toutes les propositions que les
uns et les autres pouvant porter
puissent trouver au moins une réponse
oui ou non qu'on soit au moins fixé et
que si c'est oui
dans quel délai la caméra piéton il y a
eu un effort je le disais tout à l'heure
considérable qui a été fait par le
ministre de l'Intérieur ces dernières
années 30 000 caméras il faut le
souligner mais on est quand même 117000
grades et gardiens donc il y a encore
beaucoup à faire et je pense que sur le
maintien de l'ordre on aurait tout à
gagner à généraliser le port individuel
de la caméra piéton justement pour avoir
la matérialisation de la preuve quand on
a des vidéos mon collègue le disait
encore tout à l'heure vous avez deux
secondes et là on dit on crie à la
violence policière parce qu'on voit
quelqu'un qui se prend un coup sauf
qu'on sait pas ce qui s'est appelé c'est
passé avant les conditions de
l'interpellation le comportement de la
personne et ensuite l'interpellation et
je pense que s'il y avait quelque chose
à faire en urgence c'est la
généralisation des caméras piétons et
les traceurs ADN qui permettraient de
travailler a posteriori sur les enquêtes
judiciaires
je vous remercie comme vous vous avez
pris la parole juste un élément de droit
encore une fois je veux surtout pas vous
mettre en difficulté monsieur Jacob par
rapport à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est à dire vous avez invoqué
évidemment votre devoir de réserve en
fonctionnaire partir du moment où vous
avez prêté serment dans une commission
parlementaire en réalité cela ne vaut
plus ceci étant dit évidemment je ne
vous demanderai enfin que ce soit bien
d'accord un je veux sûrement pas vous
mettre en difficulté deux il est
nullement question comment dire de vous
pousser dans des retranchements c'est
pas du tout l'objectif simplement pour
que tout le monde comprenne
effectivement
principe même d'une commission d'enquête
voilà on est dans un contexte tout à
fait particulier mais encore une fois je
vais passer la parole à Monsieur
cavalero je vais répondre il y a aucun
souci je vais donner un exemple parce
que mon organisation syndicale comme
d'autres l'ont fait quand vous avez un
élu de la République qui dit que la
police tu
voilà ça c'est le genre de discours qui
déjà qui nous fait bondir mais qui
attaillent la haine contre les forces de
sécurité et c'est inacceptable en
démocratie surtout de la part d'un élu
je remercie je pense que c'est très
clair je crois que effectivement c'est
un point qui mérite une attention toute
particulière je vous en remercie
Monsieur caveiro vous revenez un peu sur
le ce match là c'est toujours il y a
toujours une connotation aussi un peu
politique sur le matériel c'est
difficile donc c'est le préfet qui qui
décide et a toujours derrière cette on
sait d'ailleurs selon le matériaux ce
qui se passe bien ou pas bien il y aura
toujours d'ailleurs des échanges ce qui
est un peu ce qui complique aussi un peu
la chose sur le terrain des collègues ce
que aujourd'hui on leur demande beaucoup
la résilience en fait beaucoup beaucoup
de résilience face à une violence qui
est extrême et je dirais même qu'on a on
a aussi un peu inversé la rôle tout à
l'heure on parlait de moyens enfin de
moyens de mettre en oeuvre on voit
qu'aujourd'hui depuis des années en fait
on a préféré sur équiper les cancers de
police en protection corporelle c'est
une bonne chose mais en fait on l'a je
vous en sueur équipé plutôt de leur
donner les moyens d'agir soit
législatives ou autre je prends
l'exemple notamment on a sur les moyens
on a on a diminué le pourcentage de
comment s'appelle
dans les gaz des bombes à au sol des
fonctions de police pourcentage de CS on
a sur les nouvelles grenades donc les
façonnées de police disposent on a
baissé le grammage aussi pour tout ce
qui est détonation l'effet divisé par
deux donc en fait on est face à une
violence qui est qui est double qui est
triple et dans le même temps on diminue
les moyens des forces de l'ordre on voit
que les grenades sont parfois
inefficaces parce qu'en face on l'a dit
tout à l'heure ils sont protégés mais
les moyens dont ondose voilà on a
diminué le c'est comme important et je
pense je prends des grenades
assourdissantes parce que les CRS sont
actuellement dotation 9
9 par compagnie neuf petites grenades
dans le marché n'est pas passé donc les
collègues ne peuvent pas avoir sur le
matelas grenades vous avez un matière
d'or de lendemain mais ils ont plus de
Grenade les collègues ça aussi c'est
apprendre c'est aussi des Allemands à
prendre en compte parce que ça t'arrade
sur les marchés publics ou autre voilà
donc je pense qu'on a aussi inversé le
rôle c'est à dire comme Jean-Paul a dit
tout à l'heure on préfère avoir des
policiers blessés aujourd'hui c'est ça
que d'avoir en face de manifestants même
si on les avait fait sans violents parce
que une interpellation d'un individu
violent il se laissera pas faire donc
l'image choc mais quelque part le
policier n'a fait que son travail il
disait l'usage de la force de manière
proportionnée et tout le monde a été
choqué par le les collègues qui ont été
brûlés enfin pas des côtés Molotov et on
en arrive il faut aller CRS il faut
quand même savoir ils sont dotés des
cagoules anti-feu c'est un EPI
donc vous interdits aux collègues de
porter la cagoule le pays parce qu'il
faut rendre les collègues identifiables
on marche à la tête sur pas mal de
dispositifs c'est un EPI les collecteurs
pourra le garder le fonctionnement de
police est toujours identifiable dans
une compagnie de CRS vous avez ce qu'on
appelle des sept petits mots par rapport
à ça donc on sait très bien quelle
compagnie a telle heure tel endroit etc
donc voilà il y a aussi des choses à
remettre en parallèle il faut que les
collègues puissent intervenir à toute
sécurité face à des individus vers la
planche de s'insoline nous dit tout à
l'heure et ça tombe automatique de ce
que les ce qu'en face peuvent inventer
pour pour vraiment venir mutiler mutiler
ou tuer les forces de l'ordre
juste une précision parce que vos
collègues gendarmes nous ont indiqué la
semaine dernière qu'il ne disposait pas
eux de cagoule anti-feu c'est un manque
de matériel d'équipement qu'il réclame
d'ailleurs et on portera dans le rapport
non pas douter cette revendication vous
en disposez à l'inverse mais on vous
recommande de ne pas les porter ou c'est
une interdiction de ne pas les porter
est-ce que vous pouvez préciser ce point
oui alors les Français assez ont des
cagoules anti-feu depuis 2017 parce
qu'on avait été confronté à des
collègues en 2016 place de la République
était brûlée une image qui avait fait le
tour malheureusement partout
voilà donc on a dispose de cagoule
anti-feu
il y a une note de la direction centrale
on est intervenue dans les comités
d'hygiène parce qu'aujourd'hui on
demande aux fonctionnaires de de mettre
la cagoule ou de la portée au niveau du
cou et ensuite la disposer si on reçoit
un côté Molotov mais générale les
collègues déjà équipé du casque ou autre
donc en fait le collègue doivent pouvoir
la porter il y a pas de difficulté par
rapport à ça j'aurais fait je précise
c'est un autre pays un équipement de
protection individuelle aujourd'hui on
interdit parce qu'on interdit aux
collègues de la porter parce que il faut
qu'il soit identifiable il faut qu'il
soit résilient tout ça par rapport au
niveau de violence c'est ça que les
collègues ne comprennent pas
je vous en prie concernant la cagoule je
voudrais rajouter et il a dit très bien
Johan
lors de notre CHSCT maintenant formation
spécialisée CRS qui a eu lieu il y a la
semaine dernière
nous avons remis sur la table cette
histoire de cagoule de moyenne
protection vous savez que la cagoule les
sapeurs-pompiers la porte en
intervention et la cagoule elle se porte
jusqu'au niveau du nez en fait et nous
notre notre
ministère de tutelle
sous l'égide qu'il faut qu'on soit qu'on
soit
identifiable alors que on a plein de
moyens pour identifier les
fonctionnaires CRS je parle bien des
collègues CRS parce qu'il faut pas
oublier que les CRS ont des bandes de
jaune on leur numéro de compagnie sur
leur gilet tactique d'intervention ils
ont un numéro également un numéro un
alpha ou deux bravo et ils ont également
le port du Rio sur leurs manches donc
ils sont tout à fait identifiables et là
on sait on sait encore rendu compte donc
la semaine dernière que malgré cette
pays qu'on a en dotation on nous
interdit de la mettre voilà donne-nous
la mettre comme elle doit être mise
c'est-à-dire correctement c'est à dire
qu'une cagoule comme la mettre les
pompiers c'est à dire qu'elle vient
recouvrir on va dire la base du nez le
haut du nez et laisser juste les yeux
apparents voilà et les gendarmes pour
parce qu'on a parlé des gendarmes les
gendarmes eux pour se protéger de ça et
bien ils utilisent eux le masque à gaz
voilà qui le met et qu'ils enlèvent et
qu'ils enlèvent quand ils sont quand ils
peuvent être pris sous le feu de
cocktail Molotov et je veux également il
n'y a pas que les cocktail Molotov et là
je Chevette il y a également je sais pas
si vous en avez parlé c'est maintenant
la grande mode c'est les cacatov c'est
qu'on reçoit des excréments des bouts
des des excréments
ben voilà lancer envers les forces de
l'ordre voilà
qui a une odeur pestilentielle voilà et
donc et donc pour en revenir donc aux
EPI nous ce qu'on demande voilà c'est
que les fonctionnaires soient
identifiables soit mais qui puisse se
protéger également
merci beaucoup donc il y a une prise de
parole de Monsieur taverne je vous passe
la parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
Messieurs les représentants syndicaux
alors déjà une nouvelle fois comme l'a
dit ma collègue jazz vous avez tout
notre soutien bien évidemment vous
exercez un métier extrêmement difficile
et d'ailleurs de plus en plus difficile
alors moi j'ai plusieurs questions
concernant le maintiendra
puisqu'effectivement il faut être
efficace pour lutter efficacement
contrôler les groupuscules violents on
parle d'effectif de maintien de Londres
donc nous avions auditionné notamment le
directeur général la police nationale la
directrice centrale des CRS et il y a
une volonté de monter à quatre sections
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous pensez que
selon le recrutement et les sorties
d'écoles on arrivera à quatre sections
en fin d'année du moins pour arriver aux
Jeux olympiques et ce n'est pas pour
remettre en question ce qu'a dit la
direction générale la police nationale
c'est voilà est-ce que vous pensez être
sur la même ligne
concernant les l'harmonisations des
techniques on a parlé des compagnies
parisiennes etc et la directrice
centrale de la sécurité publique nous a
bien dit qu'en terme de technique
maintien de l'ordre de manoeuvre il y
avait des exercices des exercices
communs avec les compagnies
républicaines de sécurité donc est-ce
que vous pensez justement que ces
formations
cette complémentarité est utile et
efficace sur le terrain
ensuite concernant les moyens
intermédiaires la semaine dernière nous
avons auditionné les gendarmes et en
fait ils ont exactement le même discours
c'est à dire que il y a une violence de
plus en plus importante et on réduit les
moyens on prend cinq solides et 5000
grenades lacrymogènes pour 80 des
encerclements alors qu'il y avait des
meuleuses des chalumeaux etc donc
qu'est-ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
donc j'avais utilisé est un moratoire je
ne sais pas si vraiment approprié mais
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il devrait y
avoir une réflexion justement sur
l'attribution et le développement de
moyens intermédiaires justement pour
garder cette distance comme vous l'avez
dit puisque dans les autres pays ils
vont au contact et maintenant certains
les manifestants se font tirer dessus
donc il y a un moment faut revenir un
petit peu à la réalité
vous avez parlé justement du il y a un
moment des effectifs blessés d'ailleurs
je pense encore aux deux policiers qui
se sont donnés la mort ce matin
à Toulon et hier à l'école de police de
Nîmes
il y a également une vague de démission
donc est-ce que vous pensez que
justement par rapport à ce rapport avec
la violence exercée sur les effectifs
les différents discours antiphlique qui
sont prononcés est-ce que vous pensez
que justement ça provoque cette vague de
démission qui a été parfaitement
identifié par la Cour des comptes donc
est-ce que vous pouvez justement
confirmer cette vague de démission on
peut les Nationales c'est un peu plus de
10000 postes et ensuite concernant la
caméra de de surveillance en tout cas
les caméras individuelles et là bon je
sors un petit peu du contexte de
parlementaire mais il y a trois quatre
ans lors des manifestations réelles et à
Nantes nous avions utilisé des caméras
de surveillance clipsées sous les
casques
avec une extraction vidéo extrêmement
précise une qualité très nette
donc est-ce que vous savez où
ça en est ce dispositif parce que je le
trouvais à titre personnel extrêmement
efficace
et
là-dessus est-ce que voilà vous avez
interrogé que ce soit la DCS ou alors la
la DGPN et vous avez parlé de hiérarchie
sera ma dernière question
est-ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui il
y a une fébrilité sans qu'on sans
contester attention la hiérarchie
policière mais est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il y a une fébrilité par rapport au
pouvoir politique
merci
monsieur Cavalaire rouge vous en prie
alors pour répondre pour les quatre
sections de CRS je pense une utopie
parce qu'aujourd'hui
les CRS sont pour considérer avec moins
500 - 600 effectifs et on veut créer
quatre nouvelles compagnies donc
effectivement la promesse était de
revenir les compagnies CRS à cette
section pourquoi parce que derrière on
revient sur le chemin du matériel il y a
des techniques mais sections qui
s'appelle speed c'est que son protection
d'intervention une section d'appui de
manœuvre qui vient la seconde et toutes
les techniques en tout cas la dot la
doctrine opérationnelle des CRS est
basée sur quatre sections je pense
qu'aujourd'hui d'ici la fin de l'année
on n'aura pas on n'aura pas retrouvé le
niveau des quatre sections
malheureusement malgré les promesses et
l'engagement qui était pris aussi au
niveau des quatre compagnies qui sont
censés être créés ce serait 800 et TPT
pour la direction centrale des CRS on
peut vous dire qu'on les aura pas et on
sera pas niveau
là aussi où il faut faire attention
c'est qu'il y a
considéré comme on veut maquiller un peu
les effectifs c'est à dire que vous
regardez le référentiel CRS on les
effectifs de référence qui peuvent
varier de 135 le mois suivant 132 donc
effectivement quand au début de 3 les
lampes de collègues par compagnie tu
perds 60 vous gagnez tout de suite 200
effectifs or les 200 effectifs c'est du
enfin voilà on a on a maquillé les
chiffres le vrai chiffre dans une
compagnie c'est 140 145 pour arriver
vraiment à quatre sections pleines 18 en
section donc pour répondre à votre
question on n'aura pas on aura on sera
pas revenu au niveau de de quatre
section pour les caméras effectivement
ça avait été expérimenté c'était très
bien parce que c'était un dispositif qui
pourra une vision qui était intéressante
après je pense au niveau du Selmi où les
marchés seront dans le cas des marchés
publics donc je pense que c'est là où ça
ça pêche un peu par rapport à ça et pour
pas mobiliser toute la parole juste sur
le dernier point oui je pense que bon il
était au niveau de la hiérarchie parce
que des fois on CRS on a des gens qui
viennent de l'extérieur qui connaissent
pas forcément la maison CRS qui font
qu'un passage donc les sachants on en
garde mais on a un problème de
recrutement aussi en CRS on avance on
est des officiers qui faisaient toutes
leurs carrière c'est plus le cas
auparavant on a des collègues
effectivement des fois les gens
prévisibles puissent leur carrière que
la maison donc c'est vrai que des fois
il y a une certaine fébrilité dans le
cadre des ordres mais on peut comprendre
aussi parfois par rapport à la situation
mais c'est moi je pense toujours aux
collègues de terrain parce que commander
dans une salle dans une salle avec des
écrans c'est bien mais il faut aussi
écouter le terrain les les caméras de
surveillance les drones ça doit être un
appui complémentaire au dispositif de
terrain ça doit pas que tout guider et
je reviens un petit peu la formation
revient toujours même chose la formation
La formation on voit d'aujourd'hui ou le
sur emploi des compagnies de CRS on a un
sur emploi alors qu'il se passe rien on
est en train de mettre en danger la
maison CRS on peut plus se former mais
là c'est dangereux je pense qu'on arrive
à un point où il faut vite rétablir les
choses et rétablir l'équilibre
pardon il y a d'autres demandes de prise
de parole donc je vais donc je crois
qu'il y a d'autres d'autres volontés de
réponse
alors c'est concernant l'harmonisation
l'harmonisation des techniques entre on
va dire la sécurité publique et les
forces mobiles qui sont les gendarmes
les gendarmes et les CRS dans le cadre
du sMMO il est vrai que des formations
communes devaient être mises en place
devait être mise en place au sein de la
police nationale il y en a qui sont mis
en place mais
depuis on va dire déjà depuis on va dire
bientôt quatre ans que le sMMO a été mis
en place trois ans et demi
on pêche énormément au niveau de ces
pratiques
de cette pratique là de se former de se
former de former on va dire la sécurité
publique au maintien de l'ordre avec
avec les compagnies de sécurité parce
qu'il faut savoir que les compagnies de
sécurité sont à l'heure à un emploi de
haute intensité puisque
en France nous avons 60 et une Compagnie
républicaine de sécurité et que nous
employons actuellement
43 unités jours ce qui ne permet pas en
fait de rendre les repos les repos que
les fonctionnaires ont gagné et donc on
va amputer sur les formations des des
collègues on va amputer sur leur
neutralisation parce qu'on neutralise
une compagnie à la fin de leur
déplacement donc ça joue énormément
énormément sur le moral des troupes et
ce qui également amène
peut-être comme la dimension le député a
peut-être des des démissions de la part
de certains collègues qui en ont
peut-être ras-le-bol de tout ce qui se
passe voilà
peut-être le salaire le salaire des
fonctionnaires de police qui n'est
peut-être pas en adéquation avec les
risques pris par les par les par par mes
collègues de terrain voilà peut-être
cette cette
campagne également de dénigrement
permanent là je rejoins monsieur Jacob
quand il a dit
quand un élu de la République a dit la
police tu c'est vrai que mais pour nous
fonctionnaire de police ça fait mal quoi
on n'est pas là pour tuer au contraire
on est là pour on est les garants de la
de la paix public et ça il faut pas que
il faut que que les gens le sachent dans
les manifestations on est là pour que la
manifestation se passe dans le meilleur
la meilleure des façons nous on est là
pour que les gens manifestent librement
et ce qui est prévu dans notre
Constitution on est là on n'est pas là
pour casser la manifestation ou ou quoi
que ce soit on est là pour protéger les
manifestants et endiguer les violences
qui peuvent être commises lors de ces
manifestations voilà
merci beaucoup oui monsieur Jacob merci
monsieur le Président pour répondre
succinctement sur les moyens
intermédiaires j'ai fait plusieurs
propositions donc je reviens pas dessus
je pense qu'il y a des réflexions à
conduire je pense qu'elles sont même
urgentes
je voulais réagir sur la fébrilité du
pouvoir politique
c'est pas la fébrilité vis-à-vis du
pouvoir politique c'est la fébrilité
vis-à-vis du politique en général parce
que aujourd'hui et bien la police est au
cœur est au centre de toutes les mises
en cause dès qu'il y a un problème tout
de suite c'est la faute la
responsabilité de la police et forcément
la hiérarchie est particulièrement
prudente sur les consignes et les ordres
qu'elle peut donner quand on efface un
Rodeo urbain un refus d'obtempérer ou
surtout autre théâtre de mission de
police et que pour reprendre ce que je
viens de dire Jean-Paul on n'est pas là
pour tuer on n'est pas là non plus pour
se faire tuer
je pense qu'il faut aussi aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on a on a des individus dont
l'objectif c'est on va se faire un flic
voilà il faut qu'on lui faut qu'on le
qu'on lui jette à cocktail Molotov qu'on
l'incendie qu'on le blesse voir qu'on le
tue il y a encore eu une affaire il y a
quelques jours ou des collègues se sont
fait traîner dans le cadre d'un refus
d'obtempérer et c'est du quotidien et
que oui je dirais c'est normal qui est
une une
fébrilité de la part de la hiérarchie
parce que derrière il va y avoir des
conséquences la mise en cause de la
police
la mise en cause des policiers un
policier qui est mis en cause dans une
affaire mais je sais pas si les gens en
général ont conscience de l'impact
psychologique que ça va avoir sur le
policier sur sa famille tout de suite il
va être suspendu manière à titre
conservatoire dans le cadre de l'enquête
il va être passé en garde à vue
potentiellement il va être
il va être
excusez-moi je commence à fatiguer
sa famille par la médiatisation va voir
que le père ou la mère a été mise en
cause dans une affaire les enfants à
l'école ce qu'on peut lui dire sur sur
ses parents bref tout ça fait que
effectivement cette fébrilité je dis pas
que je l'accepte mais je la comprends de
la part d'une hiérarchie qui est
particulièrement prudente à laisser les
policiers à Lille jusqu'au bout de leur
mission quand il s'agit d'interpeller un
individu qui a commis un rodéo urbain
qui a renversé un enfant ou quelqu'un
qui a qui a fait refus d'obtempérer et
pareil qui va aller tuer quelqu'un oui
la fébrilité elle existe mais elle a
fébrilité elle est due aux politiques en
général elle est due aux médias est-ce
que ça aussi je pense qu'il faut le dire
et on est assez les médias pour
travailler aussi avec eux dans le cadre
de notre activité syndicale mais
malheureusement on va un peu vite en
besogne quand il s'agit de parler d'une
affaire de police et trop vite on les
met sur la place publique comme étant
des des auteurs de délit ou de crime et
puis avec le recul de l'enquête et j'ai
en mémoire une affaire qui a défrayé la
chronique c'est l'affaire Théo où on a
eu à peine une minute de vidéo qui a été
diffusée où on a accusé les policiers
d'un viol avec une menace d'assise et il
a fallu attendre plusieurs mois pour se
rendre compte que la vidéo ne faisait
pas une minute et 11 mais 11 minutes et
de voir que l'effet oui il y a eu des
faits des faits incontestables graves
mais sans la volonté
de les faire et que de l'assise je crois
si je ne me trompe pas on est passé dans
une affaire correctionnelle donc oui il
y a une fébrilité et il faut que on
requiet on reconquière ce respect qui
est dû à l'autorité de l'État et pour
n'importe quel représentant de l'État et
je pense aux enseignants aux infirmières
enfin tout ce qui représente l'état puis
qu'aujourd'hui quand on s'en prend à
nous
c'est s'en prendre à l'état et on s'en
prend à nous parce qu'on veut s'en
prendre à l'état et donc il faut
renforcer ce respect de l'autorité qui
nous élu
merci beaucoup j'ai passé à la parole à
Monsieur Mendès et ensuite encore un
monsieur Guimard puis je pense que ce
sont les dernières reprises de parole
puisque nous approchons 20 heures
merci monsieur le Président merci à vous
madame monsieur pour toutes ces
informations
vous avez raison sur un point quand on
vous attaque quand on attaque un
représentant de l'État on attaque
l'ensemble du système républicain ce
qu'on veut faire tomber le gouvernement
d'ailleurs certains partis politiques
l'assume pleinement pour changer de
système et faire tomber la République et
justement c'est aussi la base de Maxence
que vous avez apporté une réponse tout à
l'heure c'est un interpellation de
monsieur le Président mais dans les
manifestations on a vu à plusieurs
reprises sur les réseaux sociaux ou même
sur les images
des propres parlementaires parfois et
même des médias des membres
représentants l'Assemblée nationale des
partis politiques des élus du territoire
prendre des positions être présent dans
des manifestations qui étaient
interdites alors que logiquement elle
devrait montrer l'exemple à être garant
des lois de la République est-ce que on
vous a remonté des noms de personnes qui
ont été au contact dans ces
manifestations qui étaient des élus on a
en commission d'enquête notre rôle c'est
de la vérité rien que la vérité toujours
la vérité donc l'idée c'est quand même
qu'on puisse faire en sorte de démontrer
s'il y a à cointance ou pas de certains
partis politiques ce qu'on parle depuis
tout à l'heure de dérive des récrés
républicaines est-ce qu'il y a
accointance ou pas de certains certaines
associations de certains partis
politiques de certains syndicats on ne
me jette pas tout le monde dans le même
sac c'est pas notre responsabilité non
plus c'est notre responsabilité c'est de
démontrer qu'il y a des individus qui
fonctionnent de cette façon et qui
justement jettent de l'huile sur le feu
en permanence pour pousser des personnes
à vous incendier à vous jeter des pavés
à vous cracher dessus à vous insulter en
permanence et on l'a vu avec les gilets
jaunes à plusieurs reprises d'ailleurs
où on préférait défendre j'allais dire
celui qui agressé la jambe police ou le
gendarme plutôt que de soutenir l'agent
de police ou le gendarme on a vu cet
échange à l'époque avec Jean-Michel
Fauvert que j'en parle volontairement
parce qu'il y a une commission d'enquête
je rappelle au mandat précédent que nous
avions mis en place dont il était
rapporteur sur le maintien de l'ordre
pour permettre justement d'apporter des
réponses et on a pu démontrer la
différence entre le maintien de l'ordre
en Île-de-France du moins à Paris et
dans le reste de la France parce que
globalement ça se passe différemment
dans le reste de la France et ce qu'on a
pu voir à sainte-soly nous
potentiellement ce week-end
dans la vallée de la Maurienne avec le
tunnel est assez exceptionnel c'est à
dire dans le reste de la France
maintenant qu'on sait tout ça qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez nous préconiser en
complément au-delà du matériel et des
moyens humains complémentaires et vous
l'avez dit certaines personnes quittent
la police mais d'autres veulent y
rentrer aussi pour protéger le système
républicain comme on pouvait nous
accompagner justement cette transition
et je repose ma question et
volontairement est-ce que vous auriez
des personnes que vous avez vu ou des
non comptez remontés de personnes qui
étaient présentes dans les
manifestations et qui ont eu des
comportements qui peuvent être
répréhensibles aux yeux de la loi pas
simplement la présence d'une
manifestation interdite mais pour le
reste
monsieur Jacob je vous en prie oui je
vais répondre très rapidement non on n'a
pas de très honnêtement aucune remontée
de personnalité très ciblées c'est
plutôt le propos global et général que
l'on peut avoir sur différents sujets
dans lequel il y a une action de police
qui est condamnable et pour lequel on
connaît tous les slogans parce que c'est
des slogans qui sont utilisés j'ai dit
tout à l'heure la police tue on a eu
aussi pendant une période dans les
manifestations suicidez-vous on l'a
entendu des centaines et des centaines
de fois mais de dire que tel ou telle
personnalité publique a pris la
responsabilité de le faire de manière
très ouverte non
je pense que on a quand même à faire à
des gens suffisamment intelligents pour
pas prendre ce risque et d'avoir un
propos beaucoup plus généraliste et
global que de se mettre en avant et de
participer à la vindicte populaire mais
le message politique de certaines
personnes il contribuent malheureusement
dans le cadre du débat public sur sur
tout ce qui touche à la sécurité
ce qu'il y a d'autres oui monsieur
nassimato et puis ensuite monsieur
cavalero je crois que c'est Monsieur
Broué non
les vidéos enfin vous pouvez voir pardon
excusez-moi donc concernant les PC
personne politique il y en a qui vous
allez sur des sites des plateformes en
ligne de vidéos et vous allez voir
certaines personnalités politiques et
vous les reconnaîtrez oui
porter un message un message on va dire
antirépublicain oui
envers également envers les forces de
l'ordre et je voulais revenir à la
première manifestation de sainte Soline
je sais pas si la première manif ou qui
a été quand même un petit peu plus
houleuse et où on avait il me semble que
c'est le président
du Parti communiste français qui était
présent et lorsqu'il s'est présenté au
niveau de des écolos qui étaient là il
s'est fait il s'est fait sacrément
sacrément Raboué quoi je veux dire en
fait il y a
il y a deux mondes il y a deux mondes il
y a il y a le politique qui est qui est
ici autour d'une table et il y a il y a
ceux les écologistes qui qui sont sur le
terrain et ces gens-là font la
différence entre
écolo écolo partis politiques et colo
écolo de terrain voilà et il avait été
cette vidéo il avait été je veux dire ce
président de parti politique avait été
sacrément sacrément molesté par par ces
par ses individus voilà
mais après là je rejoins monsieur Jacob
mais c'est vrai que c'est
il y a on va dire qu'il y a je veux dire
à l'Assemblée nationale un parti qui qui
attise qui attise la haine en typhique
et ça on peut pas se le cacher et ici
tout se présente on le sait très bien
des petits mots c'est
tout le temps des sous-entendus mais ils
existent ils existent les collègues les
écoutent nous au niveau syndical on dit
qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur ces messages
qui sont envoyés envers envers la police
voilà donc et nous on est là on essaye
de faire le tampon nous partenaires
sociaux dire voilà vous inquiétez pas il
y a eu déjà plusieurs dépôts de plainte
de la part de syndicats policiers envers
des hommes des hommes politiques sur des
propos qui ont été tenus
donc
voilà mais c'est vrai que sur je pense
sur les plateformes vidéo vous pouvez
voir oui des gens peut-être s'interposer
même à des interpellations oui
s'interposer à des interpellations c'est
une entrave à l'action judiciaire donc
là on est on est clairement dans un
délit
oui tout à fait et moi en fait vous avez
des lors de manifestations
manifestations qui sont passées quand
vous avez un élu de la République qui
porte l'écharpe tricolore nous
fonctionnaires de police quand on essaye
d'interpeller ou qu'on fait une charge
bondissante mais cette personne là on
essaye de l'éviter voilà mais elle est
là elle est là voilà
et on l'a eu ça à plusieurs plusieurs
reprises voilà on est voilà
cette personne là si elle est là avec
son écharpe tricolore elle peut je veux
dire elle va créer un sentiment
d'impunité on va dire pour les gens qui
sont autour de lui se dire non mais on
est avec peut-être monsieur le député
mais on les fonctionnaires ne vont pas
charger de la même manière sauf que
quand on a des instructions bon mais le
député on va on va dire il va être
ménagé sur l'interpellation
mais sur la charge voilà mais oui bien
sûr qu'on a à faire des fois des
politiques oui qui s'interposent qui
s'interpose à des charges à des charges
mais comme l'a dit également on a on a
en fait sur le snoo on avait essayé
notre ministre de tutelle avait essayé
de mettre en place en fait vraiment de
pouvoir distinguer les journalistes
qu'on puisse en fait travailler enfin
travailler assez librement bon ça a été
quelque chose qui n'a pas été retenu et
ça ça gêne énormément l'action de
l'action de la force publique l'action
du rétablissement de l'ordre public
parce qu'on sait pas qui est journaliste
voilà dans les manifestations
il y a aucun brassard aucune
identification contrairement aux
fonctionnaire de police
donc voilà c'est et pour nous des fois
c'est particulièrement particulièrement
difficile d'intervenir parce que quand
on intervient également et ici dans
cette salle il y a un collègue qui est
quand même qui est qui
qui est qui est
ftsi et qui sait que lors des
manifestations lors d'interpellation
violente lors de maïs on a cette effet
tunnel en fait qui se fait c'est humain
c'est voilà on ne voit pas ce qui se
passe ce qui se passe à l'extérieur mais
on voit ce qui se passe devant on
regarde pas ce qui se passe de chaque
côté et voilà après voilà il peut y
avoir des des violences qui sont commis
par des violences illégitimes commis par
les forces de l'ordre et celle là elles
sont lourdement sanctionnées par notre
hiérarchie lourdement sanctionné
mais après au niveau des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité je sais pas si
Madame la directrice Madame Pascal
Dubois vous avez part des remontées
qu'elle a au niveau des enquêtes
judiciaires au niveau de l'IGPN au
niveau des CRS sur les centaines
d'enquêtes qui sont ouvertes suite aux
manifestations
les CRS il y en a une
voilà c'est ce que je veux dire c'est
que voilà les spécialistes du maintien
de l'ordre voilà il y a une enquête qui
est ouverte et c'est tout pour le moment
voilà
merci beaucoup je crois qu'il y avait
encore demande de prise de parole de
Monsieur
pas grand chose à rajouter de ce qui est
te dire en fait juste ce qui est
particulièrement malsain c'est que le la
remise en cause de on peut on peut
comprendre qu'à un moment sur on fait
particulier on puisse estimer dire bon
l'interpellation est pas clair il y a un
problème qui a peut-être eu des
violences illégitimes mais là le vrai
problème c'est que c'est la remise en
cause systématique de toute action de
police qui est systématiquement c'est
des violences illégitimes quelle que
soit le le fait constater il y a pas de
il y a pas de réflexion c'est
systématique et c'est ça qui pose
problème et en fait après aussi pour le
recrutement on est quand même dans des
périodes qui sont particulièrement
difficiles en recrutement et on est on
est dans des dans des moments où quand
même le policiers doit se cacher les
enfants ne doivent pas dire que que ses
parents sont policiers et ça incite
d'une part bien évidemment pas de son
site pas ses parents
à le pousser vers ce vocation et de deux
c'est quand même très contraignant dans
la vie voilà
oui je vous en prie Monsieur 30 secondes
je pense aussi pour les élus je pense
pas nous on a un code de anthologie je
pense aussi exister par les passants qui
existent donc c'est après s'en interne
comme nous on a aussi des conseils chez
nous qui arrivent dans ton logique que
ça peut faire au delà des élus je pense
aussi il y a une autre qui est aussi
symptomatique c'est le Syndicat de la
magistrature qui envoie des contre
circulaires relatives au traitement
judiciaire des infractions commises à
l'occasion de manifestants des
regroupements donc là aussi c'est aussi
un sujet qui contredit un peu l'action
qui a envoyé à tous les présidents de
cour d'appel et qui dénoncent dedans
tout ce qui peut être référence au
finance policière c'est pas non plus un
bon signe qui je l'ai à votre
disposition au besoin
oui est-ce qu'on peut effectivement
avoir communication de ce document parce
que c'est c'est intéressant parce que si
là il y a ce type de d'informations qui
circulent on est on est prudents merci
pour cette précision il y avait encore
monsieur Guimard je vais vous passer
évidemment la parole aussi je fais très
vite merci monsieur le président
d'abord je voudrais quand vous dire très
rapidement je ne crois pas que ce soit
la place d'un élu d'être dans une
manifestation interdite et la plupart
des élus le considère comme ça je vais
vous dire aussi que je suis très choqué
d'entendre que des élus
s'interposent
empêche des interpellations les élus ne
sont pas au dessus des lois et au
contraire ils sont particulièrement
soumis aux lois et doivent être
respectueux des lois donc ça ça me
choque beaucoup deux points très
rapidement pour pas prolonger sur la
parole publique je relisais donc une
élue déclarait les forces de l'ordre ne
sont plus au profit du maintien de la
paix mais sont en défense d'un projet
politique voilà je voulais votre
sentiment là-dessus j'ai déjà quand même
une vague idée mais je voulais quand
même vous dire cette phrase qui moi me
choque beaucoup et avoir votre sentiment
et un deuxième point plus technique leur
d'audition précédente
il a été expliqué que la technique de
maintien de l'ordre
visé plutôt à tenir à distance les
manifestants plutôt que d'aller au
contact or parfois on entend que les
policiers
chercheraient des incidents
chercheraient des contacts pour
commettre des violences je voudrais
votre avis là-dessus je crois que c'est
les gendarmes qui nous avait expliqué
que la priorité c'était cela maintenir à
distance pour éviter justement des
incidents votre avis sur ces deux points
merci beaucoup donc monsieur cavalero
monsieur Jacob juste après
par rapport à la phrase
on n'est pas en face par rapport à ça
les policiers déjà ils sont républicains
donc ils agissent par rapport au texte
de loi uniquement par rapport au texte
de l'ouest de considère voilà donc le
propos de la déplacer et ensuite
effectivement on maintient à distance
mais lorsqu'on va en contact c'est les
casseurs voilà c'est il faut résumer
comme ça c'est à dire que quand vous
disais tout à l'heure pour nous une
bonne manifestation c'est une
manifestation où on intervient pas tout
s'est bien déroulé le ça reste le matin
à distance reste l'objectif des forces
de l'ordre mais lorsqu'on intervient en
contact c'est lorsqu'il y a des casseurs
voilà donc les collègues enfin les les
policiers interviennent parce qu'il y a
des exactions qui sont commises
lorsqu'on va devenir fécation il se
passe rien il y a pas de contact on
reste à distance on gère et puis voilà
les collègues on est passé dans une
phase au contact parce qu'il y a eu
depuis pas sur les groupuscules violents
ou il faut intervenir dès le départ
voilà la différence elle doit être faite
aussi par rapport à ça le dans 90% des
cas on se met à distance et c'est ainsi
on les endire pas l'aile souvent on est
cachés parce qu'on nous cache sur des
choses et puis voilà mais ce que
lorsqu'on intervient c'est parce qu'il y
a des actions qui sont commises des
forces de l'ordre ou des gens aussi qui
sont agressés parce qu'on a pas le pas
non plus et aussi parfois les services
dehors du syndicats qui sont engraissés
par les casseurs ou des gens qui
viennent ou autre ou dans des banques
etc on le voit aussi voilà donc il faut
bien différencier par rapport à ça
également
merci beaucoup monsieur Jacob
on risque d'être dondan oui les
policiers sont des policiers
républicains ils sont pas au service
d'un pouvoir ils sont au service de
l'État alors je vais passer peut-être
pour un vieux policier mais j'en ai vu
des ministres de l'Intérieur depuis
1988 de toute alternance politique que
ce soit je pense pas que j'ai changé ma
façon d'être policier sur le terrain et
donc voilà donc à un moment donné c'est
vrai que c'est là aussi très
usant pour nos collègues d'entendre une
parole publique dire que la police
serait le bras armé de tel pouvoir en
place c'est complètement faux et
excusez-moi ça va peut-être être un peu
brut comme propos mais le politique
passe la police reste donc voilà donc et
les policiers continueront à faire leur
travail de policiers pour défendre la
démocratie et notre République est sur
le contact le maintien de contact je
confirme ce que dit mon collègue Johan
cavalero
oui la priorité c'est de maintenir pas
au contact pardon c'est pas lapsus le
maintien d'ordre à distance oui c'est la
priorité de maintenir à distance pour
éviter toute confrontation et en général
quand il y a confrontation c'est parce
que on a instruction de mettre un terme
aux troubles à l'ordre public
merci beaucoup bien écoutez madame
messieurs je vous remercie très vivement
d'avoir contribué aux travaux de la
commission d'enquête nous resterons en
contact parce que nous nous aurons nous
serons peut-être amenés à voir quelques
échanges par rapport à vos réponses
écoute écrite mais en tout cas vraiment
un grand merci pour la qualité de
l'échange que nous avons pu avoir au
cours plus de deux heures d'audition
vraiment nous vous en sommes extrêmement
reconnaissants mes chers collègues nous
nous retrouvons ce soir dans moins d'une
heure donc à 21h précise dans cette même
salle pour l'audition cette fois-ci à
huis clos du directeur général de la
Sécurité Intérieure et donc je lève la
séance et nous nous retrouvons pour 21h
dans la même salle donc puisque nous
pouvons rester ici pour l'audition tout
à l'heure merci encore